Ja, heute sind wir ein bisschen früher, da ist noch keiner da, doch ein Zuschauer, aber
das bin ich selbst, das ist mein Vorschaubrowser, ach da ist Flo690 da, jetzt geht es aber ab
jetzt, jetzt hat Twitch Notifications verschickt, 1337, 1337, 1337, 1337, 1337, das ist ja sowas
von Elite hier, jetzt auch am Start, AppleTV, Ande, Crash, Fluffy, Wolle, Sieg, Bert, ich
hab auf die Uhr geguckt, ja, ich weiß, dass es ein bisschen früher ist.
War Stream live seit Null bis, ja, wahrscheinlich buggt es ein bisschen rum.
Gibt es eigentlich schon mittlerweile, wo wir gerade beim Thema Twitch sind, gibt es
schon einen neuen Ad-Blog, oder, ja, U-Blog-Geschichte, dass Twitch-Ads wieder geploggt werden, wobei
darf man da überhaupt drüber reden, ist das Mokathos, ich schau natürlich alle Ads auf
allen Streams, ist klar, ja, ja, ein bisschen müde bin ich auch noch, aber, ich hab gedacht,
warum soll ich jetzt noch irgendwie 5-4 Spiele rumhocken, wenn ich schon wach bin, ist ja
auch total bescheuert, wozu, ich glaube das ist Mokathos, bestimmt ist das Mokathos, weil
das so Mokathos ist, sage ich dir jetzt auch weiter nichts zu, Spam vereiteln, beste Variante
kein Spam zu bekommen ist, wenn man die E-Mail-Adresse nicht rausposaunt überall, aber das kriegen
manche Leute nicht hin, und manchmal kann man sich auch überhaupt nicht dagegen wehren,
weil so komische Services wie beispielsweise Telegram und Signal und so, ja auch Zeug von
einem einfach ungefragt an andere Leute, die da schon angemeldet sind, schicken und
solche Dinge, wo ich mich frage, erzählen die nicht eigentlich, sie sind anonym und
privacy fokussiert und so, aber nee, anscheinend nicht, ehrlich gesagt ist ihnen das wahrscheinlich
vollkommen egal, solange man damit gut Werbung machen kann, Visualizing 150TB of Data, ok
Nvidia, Visualize mal, das ist mir zu big brain heute Morgen, jetzt kriege ich das kapier
schnitt, so, Zip hat doch gar
nicht gewonnen, also mein Zip ist verbreitet, aber so Sachen wie das 7-Zip-Geschichte, das
eingebaute, da hast du noch Ra und sonst was, ich meine Zip ist relativ verbreitet, aber
das liegt wahrscheinlich einfach daran, weil es einer der ersten war, die gut funktioniert
haben und gut genug funktioniert haben, dass man sich nichts anderes überlegt hat, mein
Zip an sich ist ziemlich simpel, der Zip ist eigentlich nur ein riesen Wörterbuch und
irgendwelche, ich glaube Zip besteht aus zwei Sachen, aus so einer Wörterbuchgeschichte
und irgendwie, dass es Wiederholungen abkürzen kann, glaube sind die zwei Sachen, Zip an
sich ist total simpel, gut ich muss nicht noch mehr Videos aufmachen, weil wir haben
genug Videos auf, was gucken wir da als erstes, zeig mal her, was, was gucken wir als erstes,
das ist Musik, so, depload your fire tv stick, oh das ist bestimmt auch mal gar tossig so
was im Stream anzugucken, wir dürfen nicht vergessen, das ist ja alles Amazon hier, da
weiß man ja nie, wie stellt man das Design von YouTube so ein, du gehst hier oben drauf,
dann gehst du auf Appearance Dark und sagst Dark, bei dir sieht es so aus, das blendet
erstmal alle, Leute ich hoffe ich hab euch jetzt nicht irgendwie erplinden lassen oder
so, na gut die echten Hacker-Mans haben eh ihre Sonnenbrille auf, da ist das kein Problem,
aber Flashbang, achso du meinst das da, das passiert automatisch, wenn du die Seite weit
genug ranzoomst, bei dir sieht es wahrscheinlich so aus, aber wenn du weit genug reinzoomst
dann kommen Buttons, weil YouTube dann wahrscheinlich denkt ich bin aufm Tablet oder so, das kann
man sich auch mal angucken, exquisite Musik, so wo sind wir denn stehen geblieben, ja ich
weiß gar nicht ob ich mir das zeigen darf, wie man sein Amazon Stick deploadet, allerdings
ich hab mir ja letztes Jahr oder so Firestick bestellt, weil das glaube ich für 29 Euro
oder so im Angebot war und ich mir gedacht hab, ok im Zweifelsfall verwende ich halt
einfach die Fernbedienung für mein Shield-TV, weil die Shield-TV Fernbedienung ein bisschen
sehr minimalistisch ist, um es mal so auszudrücken, ich mein die Shield-TV Remote, die alte, ich
red von der alten Shield-TV Remote, also nicht die, das ist die neue, ich mein die hier,
ne, what the fuck ist mit denen los hier, hat da einer erst einen 3D Drucker angeschmissen
oder was, das sieht da richtig reudig aus, aber ich mein die alte Shield-TV Fernbedienung,
da muss jetzt hier kaum Bilder, also ich mein die hier, ohne dieses geklipse dran, da hab
ich mir gedacht ok, wisst ihr was, wir könnten auch einfach die Fire-TV Fernbedienung verwenden,
die sieht glaube ich eher so in die Richtung, ja genau das ist die hier, da sind ein paar
Buttons mehr drauf, weil naja also dieses dran klipsen will ich ja wirklich nicht machen,
das muss echt nicht sein, ja und ich hab mir jetzt hier dann diesen Firestick gekauft,
dann hab ich mir gedacht im Zweifelsfall verwende ich ihn halt nicht, aber ich verwende halt
die Fernbedienung meinetwegen, für 29 Euro kannst du nicht viel verkehrt machen und jetzt
hab ich mir überlegt, ich hab hier zwei Monitore nebeneinander stehen und ich hab mir überlegt
ok, warum machst du nicht den Firestick einfach hier an den zweiten Monitor, den ich jetzt
als Stream-For-Vorschau verwende, warum machst du nicht einfach den Firestick da dran und
guckst da drüber irgendwie Amazon und sonst was, also natürlich bevor ich das Ding anschließe,
muss das erstmal am besten Custom geflasht oder am besten zumindest deep-loaded werden,
weil bei den Amazon Dingern, gerade bei den Amazon Fire-TV Dingern ist schon massig, massig
Kram drauf und bei den Fire Tablets auch, also das Fire Tablet kannst du gar nicht verwenden
ohne zu deep-loaden, das Fire Tablet ist voll mit Werbung und das ändert dir den Hintergrund
laufend mit irgendwelchen Amazon Zeugen, also ich verwende ja zum abends im Bett ein bisschen
Stream gucken und so, hab ich ja ein Fire Tablet, das hab ich aber auch komplett Amazon deep-loaded,
weil da bist du verrückt geworden, ne, also das ist halt kein Tablet in dem eigentlichen
Sinne was man verwenden soll, das ist aus Amazons Sicht ist das rein eine Werbeplattform
die sie günst, also die verkaufen dir zwar ein Tablet für 50 Euro, aber eigentlich ist
es nur eine Werbeplattform die du selbst bezahlen musst, mit der du ein bisschen was anderes
machen kannst als Amazon einkaufen, aber wenn es nach Amazon geht solltest du natürlich
hauptsächlich mit dem Fire Tablet ganz viel Sachen auf Amazon einkaufen, sonst lohnt sich
das ja auch gar nicht für die.
Ja das hab ich gelesen, aber das halte ich für unrealistisch, ja also irgendein Linux
Man, frag mich nicht was er jetzt genau gemacht hat, das weiß ich aus dem Kopf nicht, hat
in den Blog Eintrag gepostet, dass Microsoft vor hat seiner Meinung nach Windows durch
Linux Kernel Unterbau zu ersetzen, so, wieder da, also das halte ich aber für recht weit
hergeholt, ich meine es gibt ein paar Sachen die dafür sprechen zum Beispiel das angeblich
in der Cloud bei Azure mehr Linux Systeme laufen als Windows Systeme, aber das ist ja
auch irgendwie nachvollziehbar als Serverbetriebssystem, für die normalen Sachen die nicht jetzt gerade
Windows spezifisch sind, ist halt eine Linux Nummer deutlich besser geeignet, viele unterstützen
jetzt schon gar nichts, naja, war es nicht so, dass es mittlerweile ein riesen Act ist
aktuelles PHP zum Beispiel unter Windows zum Laufen zu bekommen, es gibt, was war denn
das letztens, irgendwas hab ich letztens gelesen, die haben ganz klar gesagt mit der nächsten
Version unterstützen wir kein Windows mehr, war das PHP oder war das MySQL, nee, irgendwann,
jemand hat gesagt unterstützen wir nicht mehr, ach hier das da, so genau PHP wird es nicht
mal richtig geben für Windows und es gibt viele Sachen die nicht unter richtig unter
Windows funktionieren, Server technisch, deswegen ist kein Wunder dass in Azure mehr Linux
läuft als Windows, zumal Linux nichts kostet und ich weiß nicht wie das mit Windows Lizenzen
in Azure ist, ob die dabei sind oder nicht, wahrscheinlich nicht so wie ich Microsoft
kenn, so zumindest der Typ meint es halt, dass Microsoft irgendwann sagt hey sie wollen
keinen eigenen Kernel mehr maintainen, aber sie machen dann einen Linux Unterbau, auf
der einen Seite, wie gesagt klingt es irgendwie erstmal zumindest halbwegs plausibel, aber
ich halte es also, es klingt insofern plausibel, weil warum sollte man, so wie es Android macht,
warum sollte man einen eigenen quasi Betriebssystem kernel und Gedöns pflegen, weil man doch
Linux verwenden kann, allerdings, das ist ja nur die halbe Miete, ja, das wichtigste
was Windows ausmacht, oder warum Windows noch so relevant ist, ist halt Treiberunterstützung
und Spiele, DirectX Kram und da bringt dir der Linux Kernel jetzt auch nicht viel, es
sei denn, es sei denn, man macht einen Aufbau auf dem Linux Kernel wieder mit Custom Patches
und dann ist natürlich die große Preisfrage, wenn man quasi den Linux Kernel so ein bisschen
so wie Android nimmt und ganz viele Custom Patches dran macht, dass es dann mehr wie
Windows ist, was Microsoft machen könnte, weil Microsoft weiß ja, wie Windows funktioniert,
dann ist halt die Frage, warum sollte man den Linux Kernel nehmen, wenn man eh erst
noch mal 2 Millionen Code Zeilen reinpatchen muss, ergibt aus meiner Sicht jetzt relativ
wenig Sinn, zumal es auch ausgeschlossen ist, dass die ganzen Windows Treiber jemals
den Linux rein kommen, da ist so viel proprietäres Zeug dabei, das wird im Leben nicht accepted
für den Linux Kernel, das kannst du komplett vergessen und es ist auch nichts, was Microsoft
einfach kaufen kann, also sprich, Microsoft kann zwar GitHub kaufen oder Minecraft kaufen
oder sonst was, aber die können den Linux Kernel nicht kaufen und deswegen können die
auch nicht einfach machen, was sie wollen und das wird schwierig, die ganzen Windows
Sachen in die Linux rein zu bekommen, weil gerade bei proprietären Treiber mit irgendwelchen
Binary Plops, da sind die Maintainer nicht so scharf drauf, die kriegst du da nicht rein,
also das wird nicht funktionieren, wie gesagt, das glaube ich einfach nicht, er erzählt
hier noch ein bisschen Zeug, warum das so sein wird, ja und genau, das habe ich auch
gelesen und er erzählt, dass zum Beispiel dieses Windows Subsystem für Linux und Proton
und so, dass das jetzt quasi der erste Schritt dahin sind, gut man muss auch sagen, ich weiß
nicht, das steht hier glaube ich auch irgendwie drin, dass sich Valve und Microsoft ja nicht
so gut abkönnen, aber das wäre wahrscheinlich nicht das Problem, wenn es um Geld geht, also
spätestens wenn es um die Chance geht, da sehen die ja da gerne auch mal drüber hinweg,
aber warum sollte Microsoft, was was gut funktioniert, nämlich der Windows Unterbau mit DirectX
und dem ganzen Zeug ersetzen, durch was, was die ganze Sache nachbaut und nicht so gut
funktioniert, also den Sinn, den Sinn verstehe ich ehrlich gesagt nicht, also ich kann es
mir nicht vorstellen, dass Windows jemals irgendwie durch Linux ersetzt wird und wenn,
dann ist es eher so in Richtung Android plus noch viel übertriebener, dass man Teile von
Linux vielleicht nimmt, man darf nicht vergessen, Windows Netzwerkgeschichten basieren heute
schon teilweise, oder immer noch muss man sagen, nicht heute schon, immer noch teilweise
auf BSD, deswegen gibt es ja unter Windows auch eine Hostdatei, habt ihr euch schon mal
gefragt warum es unter Windows eine Hostdatei gibt, das ist eigentlich was total un-Windows
typisches eine Hostdatei zu haben, aber eine Hostdatei gibt es unter Windows, weil das
BSD, ich weiß nicht ob es FreeBSD oder irgendwelche Oldschool BSD Geschichten sind, weil das
BSD, ich sage jetzt einfach mal FreeBSD, weil ich keine Ahnung, welches Netzwerkgeschichten
sind, deswegen gibt es eine Hostdatei unter, oder NetBSD, genau, und deswegen gibt es eine
Hostdatei unter Windows, also das könnte ich mir schon vorstellen, dass die Teile vom
Linux Kernel verwenden, gerade mit WSL, dass die Teile vom Linux Kernel verwenden, um dort
Sachen zu machen, die halt einfach und die unter Linux einfacher sind, zum Beispiel wenn
sie sagen, wir unterstützen kein PHP mehr unter Windows, dann ist ja die logische Konsequenz
daraus, dass man das mit WSL laufen lässt, weil da funktioniert es noch, und ich könnte
mir durchaus vorstellen, dass Microsoft das offiziell auch supportet irgendwann, ich meine,
WSL ist offiziell von Microsoft, PHP ist nach wie vor, auch wenn es immer noch ein bisschen
Paintschamp ist oder immer bleiben wird, PHP ist immer noch verbreitet, as fuck, also
warum sollten wir das nicht machen aus Microsofts Sicht, das, das könnte ich mir vorstellen,
aber gerade das, das Grafikzeug, Spielezeug, das wird dem Leben nicht durch Windows ersetzt,
wie gesagt, und wenn, sind es Teile vom Linux Kernel, so dass man das nicht wieder erkennt,
fast so ein bisschen, noch schlimmer als unter Android, ne, also das glaube ich nicht, und
das heiße Forum ist ja auch ziemlich gespaltener Meinung, wenn man sich das hier anguckt, ja,
ey, das könnte ich mir tatsächlich vorstellen, ne, das, das könnte ich, das, das ist eine
Sache, die ich mir tatsächlich vorstellen könnte, weil Microsoft ist schon hart am
einkaufen aktuell, exquisite Musik, ja, Microsoft ist ja aktuell schon hart am einkaufen,
mich wunderts, dass sie nicht auch noch TikTok gekauft haben, weil die haben Bethesda gekauft
und zig Gedöns in letzter Zeit, GitHub und alles mögliche, warum die nicht auch noch
TikTok gekauft, ne, aber das glaube ich nicht, dass das kommen wird, so wie er, so wie er
das beschreibt, das ist keine klassische Musik, das ist Mario Galaxy 1, allerdings ist das
kein, also kein wirklich Original Track, das ist irgendwelche klassische Musik Remixed,
das ist das, wie heißt das, das ist diese, diese, diese Hubworld aus Mario Galaxy, wo
das so läuft, ach so, ach so, die dürften keinen TikTok kaufen, okay, der hat mich sehr
gewundert, Microsoft ist halt so am einkaufen und die schrecken ja da auch nicht vor zurück
ein bisschen teurere Sachen einzukaufen, wenn man sich den Bethesda Kauf anguckt, ja, das
ist schon, aber das könnte ich mir echt vorstellen hier, das ist so ein Ding, das, das, das,
das halte ich gar nicht mal für unwahrscheinlich, ich muss euch ehrlich sagen, ich hab keinen
Plastenschimmer, wie so der Wert von Canonical, wie spricht man hier eigentlich aus, Canonical,
Canonical, Canonical, Canonical, ich kann bloß aussprechen und man spricht das übrigens
auch Ubuntu aus und nicht, aber die coolen Leute sprechen das aus, genauso wie die coolen
Leute Emerson sagen, oder anscheinend Shit oder so, Dinger, so aber das, das, das könnte
ich mir wirklich vorstellen, ich weiß nicht, was so der Wert von denen ist, Net Worth oder
was guckt man da, was sind denn die so wert, okay das ist aber, das ist ja, da lacht sich
Microsoft da drüber kaputt, das bezahlen, das bezahlen nie aus der, da ist doch nicht
mal die Kaffeekasse, ach Moment, nee ist das, ach doch das ist hier die Idee, guckt euch
das mal, das ist ja nix, da lacht sich Microsoft ja komplett drüber kaputt, da ist die Kaffeekasse
noch zu groß für, das bezahlen die von dem, was der CEO zur Reserve unterm Kopfkissen
liegen hat, also das könnte, das könnte tatsächlich sein, allerdings weiß ich nicht, was die davon
großartig hacken, weil Snap interessiert kein Mensch, also diese komischen, diese komische
Package Formate, nein die meine ich nicht, Snap Crap, das interessiert kein Mensch, bis
auf ein paar, die es verwenden müssen, weil sie nicht da drumherum kommen, ja Ubuntu ist
das einzige, was machen die, was machen die denn sonst noch so, nicht, was machen die
denn sonst noch so, die haben ihre eigenen Cloud Versuche, die aber auch keiner verwendet,
ja was machen die denn so, Ubuntu ja das ist das einzige, was mir so einfällt, das juckt
auch keinen, das juckt auch keinen, wobei es doch keiner, das juckt auch keinen, das juckt
auch keinen, das juckt erst recht keinen, das auch nicht, das auch nicht, das erst recht
nicht, keine Ahnung, juckt auch nicht, juckt auch nicht, das ist verbunden mit Ubuntu juckt
im Prinzip auch nicht wirklich, ist auch egal, ist auch egal, also die haben ja außer Ubuntu
nix, der Kommentator 10 Monate, exquisite Subscription, Dankeschön, Poggers, Nextcloud20 ist raus,
das müssen wir uns mal schnell angucken, was ist so Change Log, Nextcloud20, what's new,
ich schreibe mir das mal, ich schreibe mir das mal auf, das können wir tatsächlich
mal wieder uns angucken, allerdings bin ich ganz schlechter Dinge, dass das besser geworden
ist, weil Nextcloud war schon immer zu großen Teilen so unfertig und unpolished, ich kann
mir gar nicht vorstellen, dass das jetzt auf einen Schlag alles besser ist, haben die nicht
irgendwie einen Release, Release, Nextcloud20 hier, Matt V doch so viel, heute muss ich irgendwie
husten, was denn hier los, warte mal ich muss mal kurz muten, hast du dein Soundboard leiser
gemacht, ne habe ich nicht, aber manche Sounds sind ein bisschen leiser als andere, also was
gibt es denn neues in Nextcloud20, es gibt drei große neue Features, New Dashboard,
ist das das neue Dashboard, hier Christine Schrott, ach nee Schott, das ist so ein bisschen
was wie so Custom Dashboards, die man sich beispielsweise aus seinen Docker Containers
generieren kann, da gibt es ja auch so Projekte, oder, keine Ahnung, ja ok, das ist nicht verkehrt,
die Startseite von Nextcloud ist nun wirklich nicht so der Wahnsinn gewesen, ja warum nicht,
das ist ganz ganz nice, so was haben sie sonst noch, search was unified, bringing search results
from Nextcloud, ja endlich, Moment, ok also die search results von GitLab, Hira und sonst
was, dass die in Nextcloud sind ist mir ehrlich gesagt scheiß egal, Hauptsache die Nextcloud
und Nextcloud Apps selber haben eine ordentliche Suchfunktion, was sagst du zu Cryptomator
und deren Service kenne ich nicht, Talk Introduce, gut Talk juckt mich nicht, weil ich verwende
Nextcloud nur daheim und zu 95% alleine bis auf die Kalender und die Kontaktliste also
was juckt mich Talk ja, Notifications ok, Kalender integriert sich in die Suche, da
sehen wir, es ist eigentlich lächerlich, hört sich jetzt ein bisschen fies an, aber ich
meine, für eine Lösung, die hauptsächlich File und Kalender macht, dass man das Kalender
nicht schon ohnehin bisher in das Search war, ist eigentlich schon lächerlich, aber es
ist gut, dass sie das jetzt gemacht haben, ich werde es mal ausprobieren, ich wette
mit euch die Suche in Notizen und To Do's funktioniert immer noch nicht richtig, ich
könnte wetten, dass das immer noch nicht geht, das schreibe ich mir gleich mal hier
auf, das ist das erste, was wir probieren, geht Suche in To Do und Notes App jetzt, weil
eine Notizen App ohne Suche ist halt echt der Witz gewesen, ja wie gesagt, ich habe
keine Ahnung, was das ist, ich kann dazu gar nichts sagen, Deck war diese Kanbord-Born-Gesport-Geschichte,
die Track und Drop nicht mehr funktioniert hat, ok, ja, das gucken wir uns mal im nächsten
Stream oder im übernächsten Stream an, weil im nächsten Stream, das machen wir vielleicht
sogar heute Mittag noch, ich habe ja, ich weiß, ich habe gesagt am Wochenende, aber
ich habe es gestern nicht gebacken gekriegt, gucken wir uns Dings hier an, ich kann es
selber noch nicht schreibe, hier das da, das ist quasi das Betriebssystem von Synology
lauffähig gemacht auf normaler Hardware, Stripes 007 15 Monat Exquisite, so ich muss mal kurz
den Chat aufmachen, dass wenn ich ein paar Sachen besprechen will, die Sachen dann auch
auf, warum vergisst das immer mein Dark Seen, was ist denn hier los, verstehe ich nicht,
aber warum muss ich denn heute so viel husten, nicht das hier doch am Start ist, so, dann
gab es eine Frage, wollen wir anfangen mit Videos gucken, gute alte Call of Duty Zeichen,
ja gut, das ist aber schon ganz schön lange her, aber es ist schön, dass du auch deinen
Weg hierher gefunden hast, ok, kennst du den Clipboard Manager, den mit Windows plus V
aktivieren kann, ja den kenne ich, den habe ich aber hier glaube ich ausgeschaltet, nicht
dass ich aus Versehen Dinger leake, die ich mal copy pasted habe, so und dann fragt der
Wasserfreak, hat gefragt, das kann ich mal kurz vorlesen, das ist ein bisschen was längeres,
welche Sprache sollte ich für ein Backend nutzen, geplant ist alle x Minuten Schnittstellen
aufzurufen, Sachen auf eine DB zu schreiben und nach außen auch eine Schnittstelle anzubieten,
dachte mir ich versuche das mal mit Python, da kannst du fast alles für verwenden, das
solltest du mit so ziemlich jeder Sprache hinbekommen, da würde ich einfach das nehmen,
wo du Lust drauf hast, weil irgendeine API alle x Minuten abrufen, also das kannst du
ja wahrscheinlich sogar in Brainfuck machen, das sollte mit jeder x beliebigen Sprache
funktionieren, sogar in C++, ja gut in C++ funktioniert alles, es ist bloß alles eklig,
so und dann Sachen in der Datenbank schreiben ist auch kein Ding, das kriegst du auch mit
jeder Sprache hin, ist nur die Frage wie das funktionieren soll, über irgendeine Web-Interface
oder Lokale, über irgendwelche C-Libraries oder wie auch immer oder ob es SQlite ist
oder eine MongoDB oder irgendwas, aber Bindings für Sprachen gibt es da eigentlich für alles,
zu den gängigsten Datenbanken gibt es für alle möglichen Sprachen was, ja und nach
außen hin irgendeine API anbieten, kriegst du auch mit jeder Sprache hin, da würde ich
einfach nehmen, worauf du Bock hast, also das ist echt kein Ding, da würde ich wirklich
das nehmen, worauf du Bock hast, wenn du das in Python machen willst, machs in Python,
wenn du das in.NET machen willst, machs in.NET, meinetwegen sogar in Java, in Go, in
Haskell, in O'Cammell, in was auch immer, ist vollkommen egal, das kriegst du in Ruby,
das kannst du in allem, es gibt mir fällt jetzt spontan kaum eine Sprache ein in der
du das nicht machen könntest, es gibt allerdings ein paar Sprachen in der ich das nicht machen
möchte, nämlich z.B.
C++, ja, so ok, also mit was fange man an, ich hab noch jede Menge Videos vom letzten
Mal offen, weiß gar nicht wo wir das letzte Mal aufgehört haben, also wie man sein Firestick
deploatet, bin ich mir nicht sicher ob das Monkratos ist, wenn man das hier zeigt, du
kannst das sogar in wishlbasic.net machen, ja, wenn es sein muss, so was haben wir sonst
noch, look, Windows 10, coding Snake in 4 Minuten, das ist fake, Leute ich sag euch das Video
ist fake, das ist ok, das ist 3 Jahre alt, das ist fake, wollen wir wetten, dass das
fake ist, ich zeig es euch, dass das fake ist, warte mal, das ist fake und zwar, weil
in 4 Minuten 30, also ich bezweifle nicht, dass da am Endeffekt ein lauffähiges Snake
bei rauskommt oder so, das nicht, der wird das wirklich programmieren, aber wo ich sage
dass das fake ist, ist, dass der das sich live in diesen 4 Minuten 30 ausdenkt, das
ist fake, der hat sich das im Vorfeld schon ausgedacht und programmiert das jetzt einfach
runter, weil in 4 Minuten 30, da hast du dir ja gerade mal ein neues Projekt angelegt,
den Browser aufgemacht und dir überlegt, was weiß ich, wie es aussehen soll, das kannst
du vergessen, in 4 Minuten 30, guck mal, guck mal, allein schon wie das anfängt, allein
schon wie das anfängt, hallo wir machen jetzt mal zufällig Snake, ich weiß genau ich brauche
an dieser Stelle einen Canvas und, ja ja, wie wärs eigentlich mal mit Syntax Highlighting,
guck mal, wie das versucht zu faken, er versucht so nachzudenken zu faken, so, was mach ich
jetzt, ID gleich GC, ok, der ist aber, der mag das roh, ja, ja, also so ohne Syntax Highlight
ohne alles, das ist ja, allein schon deswegen glaube ich, dass es fake ist, also dass das
halt vorher schon ist und der das entweder auf dem zweiten Monitor hat zum abgucken
oder halt irgendwie vor sich liegen hat zum abgucken oder sowas und Leute, ihr wisst ja,
ich weiß wovon ich rede, weil ich hab's ja schon auf das gesagt, manche Sachen, die
ich hier im Stream mache, hab ich mir im Vorfeld auch schon angeguckt, weil ansonsten macht's
kein Spaß mir zuzugucken, wie ich 45 Minuten irgendwie versuche, rauszubekommen, wie ich
die Sache aufrufe, Exposed, das, ok, ja, gut, das, das, in Wirklichkeit, jetzt guckt
er ab, jetzt guckt er ab, jetzt guckt er grad ab, guck, guck, der hat abgeguckt, unten
liegt's Blatt oder der Monitor oder irgendwas, 100 pro Exposed, weil, ok, das lass ich mir,
das lass ich mir noch gefallen, das lass ich mir noch gefallen, dass der weiß, wie
man hier, die startende Methoden, wenn du das öfters machst, aber ich hätte jetzt schon
nachgucken müssen, ok, ist es Get Context 2D, ist es irgendwie Get CTX oder, oder sonst
was, das ist übrigens schon ein Punkt, wo man sieht, dass JavaScript mittlerweile angenehmer
ist als C++, beide Sprachen, die ich früher übelst geflamed hab, aber mittlerweile komm
ich mit JavaScript ganz gut klar, in C++ ist es immer noch so total wir, ob man ne Funktion
oben drüber oder unten drunter definieren kann, also normalerweise geht das innerhalb
von der Klasse, dass es egal ist, wo die Funktion steht, es sei denn, man muss, man muss irgendwas
als Typ verwenden, dann geht's wieder nicht, das ist, aber gut, C++ Flame muss heute nicht
sein, ja, ist alles klar, Big Brain, das denk ich mir alles on the fly aus, Retal ist gut,
Retal ist gut, ich hab aber ehrlich gesagt keine Ahnung, was wir für Serverschränke
haben, wir haben so nen fertigen, so nen komplett fertigen Schrank, also nicht ein komplett
fertiges Wreck, wir haben so nen komplett fertiger, sieht ein bisschen aus wie der Waffenschrank
aus Matrix, ok, ich spule mal ein bisschen vor, der weiß den Keycode aus dem Kopf, Moment,
das will ich jetzt mal gucken, wie er das begründet, ok, er sagt wenigstens, der weiß
es aus dem Kopf nicht, das glaub ich ihm nicht, im Leben nicht, ich glaub, also ich mein,
das sind Arrow Keys, ja, aber ich glaub ihm nicht, dass er aus dem Kopf weiß, weil das
verwechselst du mal ganz schnell, ne, also ich hab keine Ahnung, ob das Key Up, Key Down,
Key sonst was ist, ich vermute mal, dass das Arrow Keys sind, aber, Achja, kannst du uns
mal was von deiner Heizungsüberwachung, Steuerung erzählen, ja, natürlich hab ich
schon erwähnt, wie gut meine Heizungsüberwachung funktioniert, guck mal, man sieht hier wunderbar,
wie er heute Nacht geheizt hat, man sieht, wann der Brenner angegangen ist, man sieht
die aktuelle Temperatur und man sieht, Abgas Temperatur, Kessel Temperatur und ob das Ding
irgendeinen Fehler meldet, habt ihr doch glaub ich noch nie gehört, in einem der letzten
Streams, oder, aber ich muss sagen, insgesamt funktioniert echt gut, leider bin ich so doof
und hab die History nicht so lang eingestellt, ich hab bloß 15 Tage, glaub 15 Tage oder
so, History, das heißt, ich kann jetzt gar nicht gucken, meine Heizung, aber hier sieht
man, hier hab ich die Heizung zum ersten Mal wieder eingeschaltet, so um 11 Uhr, 26.09,
exquisite, ja, so, guck mal weiter, jetzt könnt ihr mich ruhig öfters fragen, ich hab keine
Schmerzen, das 20 Mal im Stream zu zeigen, weil, wenn man mal was hat, was gut funktioniert,
ist doch, ist doch toll, ne, so, also das, allein schon das ist schon mal, äh, jebait,
ja, und der Max hat auch recht, dass das von oben nach unten runterprogrammiert wird,
also normalerweise ist das auch nicht, wie gesagt, ich sag euch, das ist fake, und ich
bin dir zu 99, ja, das ist fake, jaja, natürlich, alles klar, das ist on the fly, denk ich,
spürt das alles aus, ja, klar, natürlich, das schreib ich auch alles so runter immer,
ich mein, auch wenn das, wenn das simpel ist, ja, ähm, also ich, das ist nicht schwer,
sowas zu programmieren, aber, dass man das on the fly, während man tippt, quasi sich
schon auf, während man am tippen ist von was altem, schon sich das neue on the fly ausdenkt,
sodass man ohne, never, nie, äh, oder der Typ ist sowas von big brain, dass die Twitch-Emoals
nicht ausreichen, also ich finde, der spricht ein bisschen zu langsam, wir müssen das glaube
ich hier vorstellen, also auf zweimal stellen, da hat es das, das glaube ich, ich, ich glaube
das dem nicht, ok, ich, ich spule mal ein bisschen vor, übrigens, ich glaube gar nicht,
dass er hier unten abguckt, er hat das wahrscheinlich einfach nebendran auf seinem Monitor, weil,
wir sehen es ja nicht alles, oder er ist big brain, hat sich das mehr oder weniger auswendig
gemerkt, also, es, es ist so, wenn man, wenn man sowas gebastelt hat und man soll das dann
quasi neu, äh, erzeugen, man kriegt sowas auch halb, also das jetzt vielleicht nicht,
aber vieles kriegt man, wenn man es vor kurzem gemacht hat, ziemlich gut aus dem Kopf immer
wieder rekonstruieren.
Kennst du William Lin, ja von dem haben wir auch schon ein paar Sachen geguckt, allerdings
muss man sagen, also William Lin, das ist, der, der macht so competitive programming
videos auf, auf YouTube, allerdings, bei dem ist der Fall ein bisschen anders, der macht
ja nur das und vor allem sind die Sachen oftmals, ähm, Abwandlung von schon bestehenden Dingern,
also der macht die Sachen ja auch nie zum ersten Mal im eigentlichen Sinne, der muss,
der muss, ich will, ich will das jetzt nicht schlecht reden, der muss die auch big brain
kombinieren, aber das ist, das ist fake.
Vor allem wisst ihr, wisst ihr warum, eine der obviesten Sachen, warum das fake ist,
er guckt es sich nicht einmal zwischenzeitlich an, ob es funktioniert.
Niemand schreibt so ein Snake Game, auch wenn Snake billig zu machen ist, ja, von oben
nach unten runter und am Ende geht es, ohne zwischendurch zu gucken, ob, ob das überhaupt
ansatzweise stimmt, weil, es ist ja so, wenn man anfängt und irgendwas verkackt hat und
schreibt dann irgendwie das halbe Programm runter und guckt sich dann an und stellt
auf, fuck, ich hab am Anfang was verkackt, ähm, ja, das ist fake, ich mein, allein
schon, ich müsste allein schon, gut, ich bin jetzt auch nicht der Javascript Pro, was,
was so, äh, Grafik Sachen angeht, ich müsste allein schon fünfmal zwischendurch nachgucken,
wie die unterschiedlichen Funktionen heißen, weil, der macht es ja komplett ohne Autocomplete,
ohne alles.
So.
Jaja, ich glaube, das war's jetzt, ja, vor allem, mhm, alles klar.
Ist klar.
Es geht einfach, also Leute, ihr wisst in Zukunft, wenn irgendwas nicht geht, einfach
so programmieren, dass es funktioniert.
Ganz einfach.
Easy.
Just 4Head, ja.
Wisst ihr, wisst ihr, was, wo man auch dran erkennt, dass das, ähm, fake ist, dass es
nicht nur funktioniert, sondern dass es spielbar ist.
Was ich meine ist, er müsste zumindest die Timings testen, er müsste zumindest testen,
wie, wie ist die Spielgeschwindigkeit schnell genug, ähm, kann man es überhaupt steuern
mit der Spielgeschwindigkeit und sowas.
Also, das machst du nicht intuitiv.
Du fängst mal an mit, keine Ahnung, 500 Millisekunden, stellst dann fest, okay, das ist viel zu schnell
oder viel zu langsam.
Allein schon, dass das Timing, also nicht nur, dass er sich das ganze Video nicht angeschaut
hat, auch dass das Timing perfekt stimmt, oder spielbar stimmt, halte ich auch für
recht, äh, offensichtlich fake.
Er will uns jetzt erzählen, er ist so big brain, dass er das gelernt hat in sieben Monaten,
dass man sowas herunterschreiben kann, alles klar.
Ah, okay, er will auch noch seinen Kurs verkaufen, alles klar, jetzt verstehe ich auch, was da
gehen soll.
Es ist fake, wie gesagt, es ist, es ist, es ist fake, ich bin mir da zu 99% sicher, 100%
sicher, kann es ja bei nichts sein, dass das fake ist, hat er gesagt, dass es spontan
ist, naja, er sagt, coding Snake in viereinhalb Minuten, er hat ja nicht geschrieben, ich
tippe Snake in viereinhalb Minuten ab, also, und er sagt ja auch zwischendurch so Dinge
wie, ah, ich glaube, es funktioniert jetzt und sowas, also, es soll den eindeutig den
Anschein erwecken, als macht er das jetzt live und denkt sich das live aus.
Also, wenn ich so tue, als ob, dann muss ich nicht explizit nochmal sagen, dass es so ist,
das ist so wie, okay, das ist jetzt ein schlechter Vergleich, aber, ähm, es gibt ja in Deutschland
auch Gesetze, dass du Sachen akzeptierst, ohne dass du sagen musst, ich akzeptiere,
ja, zum Beispiel kannst du bestimmte Verträge annehmen, wenn du halt schlüssige Handlungen
machst, dass du die Sachen angenommen hast, wenn du irgendwas erbst, und du fängst schon
an das Haus von, keine Ahnung, demjenigen, dem du was geerbt hast zu verkaufen, dann
nimmst du das Erbe automatisch an, ohne dass du explizit sagen musst, ich nehme es an,
ja, und, äh, also, so ist das, ich gebe dir das Beispiel zack ein bisschen, aber, so
ist das ja, er sagt nicht explizit, ich denke mir das jetzt spontan aus, aber das macht
komplett den Anschein, als soll das so sein.
Manchmal sind YouTube-Comments keine lustig, yes, genau, exakt, genauso sieht es aus,
der tippt, der programmiert nicht, er tippt einfach nur, und wie viele das einfach glauben
ist auch schon geil, wie gesagt, ähm, ich halte das für nahezu ausgeschlossen, dass
das jetzt einfach mal so runterprogrammiert wurde, gut, wurscht, weiter, was, was, was
kann man jetzt eigentlich gucken?
Gameboy Running Steam, ok, das ist eben, das ist ein Gameboy-Gehäuse, wo einen Raspberry
eingebaut hat, ja super, ja, wie gesagt, bei einer Million Abos auf YouTube, oder bei,
lass mal gucken, lass mal gucken, oder bei, ähm, oder bei, ja, sagen wir 500.000 Follower
Fritsch, was so nicht eintreten wird, easy, das könnt ihr ruhig kleppen, das tritt so
eh nicht ein, so, ähm, zumindest nicht zu unsre Lebzeit, also gut, nicht zu dir unsre
Lebzeit und nicht mit diesem Content, den ich aktuell mache, weil, so cool ich das finde,
wie viele Leute immer zugucken, auch bei den ganzen Technik-Sachen, das ist halt nix, wo
du irgendwie 10.000 Leute erreichst oder so, das will ich aber auch gar nicht, mir ist
das so viel lieber, kann ich nämlich komplett machen, was ich will, ja, Wakesauce, genau
so was, das ist ein guter Beispiel, das ist ein gutes Beispiel, ja gut, Bot zählt natürlich
nicht, wenn die Follower, wenn ich 500 Follower gebotet kriege, erstens schreibe ich dann
den Twitch-Support an, dass die wieder gelöscht werden und das sehe ich ja auch an den Zuschauern,
wenn das weiterhin dann, sagen wir mal, um die 150, 200 sind und ich habe auf einmal
500.000 Bot-Follower, dann stimmt auch irgendwas nicht, ja, so, na, das glaube ich nicht so
interessant, was haben wir sonst noch, Best Moments in Battlefield 4, das können wir angucken,
oh, die Videos sind immer gut, das schauen wir uns jetzt an, von dem haben wir uns schon
mal was angeguckt, der baut übelst nice Cases, zwar ehrlich gesagt, das ist ziemlich sinnlos,
ja, aber es sieht immer geil aus, das sind so exquisite Handwerkerskills, ah, yes, was
ist denn das, was hat er denn da, Fusion 360, ah, yes, bisschen leise, Moment, der muss
nochmal reden, viel zu leise, ok, das ist besser, exquisite, die Musik im Hintergrund
schon, der hat richtig Big Brain Musik im Hintergrund, ok, das Design, den können wir
mal überspringen, ich will eigentlich nur gucken, wie das Gehäuse am Ende aussieht,
was er da bastelt, ne, also ich habe keine 380 und 390 bekommen, was hat er denn da,
was macht er da, was macht er da, macht er ein Foto, ich habe keine Ahnung, was er da
macht, ah, ist das eine Fernbedienung für sein Fräsending, ah, yes, sowas muss der
erstmal daheim haben und ich komme mir mit meinem 3D Strucker schon übelst pro vor,
ok, das ist ultra entspannt, da schläft man wieder fast ein bei, vor allem, wenn er das
dann noch abschleift und so, das sieht dann auch immer richtig, richtig Profi mäßig
aus bei dem, ah, jetzt mal drauf gespritzt, CNC Fräse daheim ist schon Big Brain, ja,
stimmt, ich habe letztens ein Video gesehen, da hat sich einer von Aliexpress Mini-C&C Maschine
irgendwie gekauft, fragt mir nicht, 180 Dollar, zum selbst zusammenbauen, also anscheinend
gibt es das schon halbwegs erschwinglich, natürlich wahrscheinlich nicht so, was er
da hat, ruined, saved, was das, ah, das haben wir das letzte Mal schon gesehen, das sind
diese Dinger, die wollte ich mir bestellen bei Amazon, habe ich nie gemacht, das muss
ich jetzt gleich nachholen, das sind so, das sind so, das ist ein Lötkolben, das sind
quasi so Gewinde, Gewindedinger, die man mit einem Lötkolben reinschmelzen kann, ich
habe aber vergessen, wie die heißen, das brauche ich, das brauche ich, die sind richtig
Big Brain, Gewinde schmelzen, ich habe keine Ahnung, wie man die es nennt, sowas hier,
das da, das da, das brauche ich, das wird, das wird später bestellt, exellent, oh, ich
habe noch 9 Sachen im Shopping liegen, Moment, das habe ich ja schon bestellt, das habe ich
schon alles bestellt, das habe ich nicht bestellt, das auch nicht, das auch nicht, das auch nicht,
exquisite, ja, das brauche ich, das ist gut, weil das geht bestimmt auch gut für 3D geprintete
Sachen, ich meine, er macht das jetzt in, Moment, ist das, ist das Plastik, was der
da drunter hat, ist das vielleicht sogar 3D gedrucktes Plastik, was er da, was er da
hat am Start, 3D gedrucktes Plastik mit Holz drunter, könnte das, könnte das sogar, weil
hier, guckt euch mal die Spuren an, das könnte sogar 3D gedrucktes Plastik sein, es ist auf
jeden Fall Big Brain, dass man die Dinger mit einem Lötkolben rein machen kann, ja,
guckt mal, guckt mal Leute, das ist 3D gedruckt hier, das Plastik sein, was halt das coole
bei ihm ist, er macht da noch so Big Brain Holzzeugs drüber, dass es halt viel besser
aussieht, da ist ja der 3D Drucker, nee, Moment, das ist nicht der, ist das der 3D Drucker,
ich habe keine Ahnung was das ist, ja, das ist der, das ist der 3D Drucker, vermute ich
mal, ja, ja, ja, oder, es sah so aus, ja doch, guckt mal hier, das ist 3D gedruckt,
die Teile, guck mal, wie gut das passt, warum hat er das jetzt nass gemacht, oh, wie lange
machst du, weiß ich nicht, guckt mal, wie gut das ausschaut, Poggers, was löte der
denn da unten, ah, Moment Leute, wir haben uns ja schon mal ein Video von ihm angeguckt
und das war sehr ähnlich zu dem hier, aber das kann es nicht gewesen sein, weil das sind
2080TES, die gab es damals noch nicht, das ist wahrscheinlich das gleiche, was wir uns
schon mal angeguckt haben, nur mit anderer Hardware drin jetzt, weil ich war damals schon
begeistert, wie gut das Ganze zusammenpasst, was er da gebaut hat und ich bin wieder begeistert,
wie gut das Ganze zusammenpasst, kommt heute Battlefield 3, was du meinst als Video oder
als Gameplay, von mir auf, als Video, äh, warte mal, nee, Battlefield 4 haben wir glaube
ich noch ein Video, Battlefield 3 gab es keine neuen Videos, jaja, das ist jetzt auch wieder
ein 3D-Druck-Part, aber wie gut das passt, das ist wirklich exquisite Big Brain Planung,
was ist denn das, WLAN, WIFI, ach guck mal, das ist ein PCI, das ist ein PCI einfach,
auf PCI einfach und das ist eine WLAN-Karte, guck mal, der hat sogar, der hat sogar Schrauben,
wie heißt das, Versenkungsdinger gemacht für die Schraubenköpfe, mich würde ja mal interessieren,
wie warm das Ding wird danach, also wie gut er da irgendwie einen Lüftungsstrom hinbekommt
oder einen Luftstrom hinbekommt, guck mal, wie gut das passt, was er da gebaut hat alles,
ok das ist wirklich Next Level Planung, dass das geht, was ist das, irgendeiner, der sich
den Mini-Rechner selbst zusammenbaut, einem selbstgebauten Gehäuse, was extrem gut passt,
ok der weiß auf jeden Fall was er macht, also bei mir wäre auf jeden Fall dieses Teil schon
zu lang, dass das Teil dranstoßen würde und sowas, deswegen ich würde sowas gar nicht
bauen, nicht schlecht, ich mein das da alles reinzukriegen ist schon, schreck mich nicht
so, was, wie viel, wie viel, 370 Watt, naja, wird es wahrscheinlich auch ein bisschen warm
drum herum, mal gucken wie das, mal gucken wie die Temperatur ist, wenn er das zu macht,
stimmt, ach nee, der macht ja gar nicht richtig zu, da hat er überall Lüftungsschlitzen,
das ist ja eigentlich noch viel besser, ich mein das sieht geil aus, das hat, das hat
irgendwie schon, also ich muss euch sagen, ich finde das hier, gut, das grüne sticht
ein bisschen raus, das sieht kacke aus, wahrscheinlich hätte er aber die Karte auch lieber in schwarz
genommen, wenn sie die gegeben hätte, hat er wahrscheinlich nicht gegeben, also das sieht
deutlich edler aus, als ein RGB beleuchteter PC mit so einer Plexiglasscheibe dran, allerdings
was dort Probleme machen wird, ist, das hat keine Staubfilter und spätestens, spätestens
nach einem halben Jahr, wenn es im Wohnzimmer steht und ich mein, gut ich weiß nicht, ob
sein Mops großartig hart oder so, aber wenn Mike Hat sich da daneben liegt, daneben liegt,
da ist nach zwei Wochen wahrscheinlich das Ding verstopft, also gerade, gerade, dass es
keine Staubfilter hat, ist natürlich ein bisschen problematisch, das heißt du musst
das nach einem halben Jahr auseinander nehmen, wenn du ordentliche Kühlung wieder haben willst,
gerade weil das so offen ist, aber gut aussehen tut es, das sieht wirklich sehr edel aus,
was ist das, und jetzt spielt er WoW drauf, geil, beste Beschäftigung schlechtern, erst
mal ein System gebaut mit einer 2080 Ti und dann erst mal WoW angeschmissen, exquisite,
find ich gut, was haben wir als nächstes, day in the life of a data center, ja das,
das gucken wir uns gleich noch an, was haben wir sonst noch, Spiele im Oktober, an manchen
Tagen läuft es nicht, ich glaube er hat irgendwas kaputt gemacht, wir gucken uns jetzt das Video
vom Bauer an, der Auer, ich muss eben mal gucken, das Problem ist, ich bräuchte mal
für Youtube so einen Kompressor für meinen Browser, der die Sachen immer gleich laut
gemacht hat, Hauptsache Staubfilter, ach wobei, ja doch, da oben sind auch Lüfter, ohne
Staubfilter geht nix, das hier hinten ist es ja ok, aber Staubfilter, wichtigste, deswegen
sollten ja auch immer mehr Lüfterluft reinziehen als rauspusten, dass man quasi, äh warte mal
Unterdruck, Überdruck, Big Brain Marks Überdruck hat im Gehäuse, ne, genau, dass man Überdruck
im Gehäuse hat, dass kein Staub rein kommt, wow, ich geb zu es hat was, ich geb zu es
hat was, ich würd's mir nicht hinstellen, aber es hat was, ja, aus ist kaputt, aber
ist doch egal, Hauptsache RGB geht, ich mein wer will damit spielen, man kann's hinstellen
in den Hintergrund und kann RGB anlassen, ja das muss erstmal untersucht werden, a exquisite,
exquisite
Aber selbst in dieser Minimalkonfiguration startet das System.
Razor sagt, interessant, wahrscheinlich ist es eher Race-O-W, denke ich mal.
Interessant wäre auch mal, ob die Katze einen Kurzschluss verursachen könnte.
Ja, wenn du an die falschen Stellen schreibst, stellen die einen Kreis bestimmt.
Aber gerade die teuren Boards, die sind mittlerweile ziemlich abgedeckt an den meisten Stellen.
Also ich glaube, es ist nicht so einfach mit purem Draufgreifen dort Kurzschlüsse zu fabrizieren.
Aber klar, möglich ist es auf jeden Fall.
Also möglich ist es auf jeden Fall, wenn du jetzt wirklich eine dofe Stelle hast.
Aber es ist recht unwahrscheinlich.
Ja, rückt mir den Haar nicht, aber die Katze hat ja unten auch an den Pfoten Haut.
Also es könnte schon sein.
Aber gerade bei den teureren Boards denke ich eher nicht.
Wo das passieren könnte, ist zum Beispiel, wenn die hier an irgendwelche Pins greift.
Also wenn die hier irgendwelche, die haben ja auch kaum offene Pins.
Ja, die hier ist egal, da ist ja eh nichts dran.
Also unglücklich, also passieren kann es an der falschen Stelle.
Beispielsweise, wenn die hier irgendwie zwei Füßchen miteinander verbinden.
Könnte schon sein, aber ich glaube, es ist nicht so akut.
Das ist doof.
Bedeutet ist es entweder das Mainboard, was ein Problem hat oder vielleicht der Speicherkontroller in der CPU.
Der Socket sieht gut aus, also daran liegt es auf jeden Fall nicht.
Alter, guck mal, wie fett die Dinger mittlerweile sind.
Was ist denn das für ein Board?
Socket, was? Das sind Threadripper.
Socket 4.0, irgendwas.
Ich glaube, das ist ein Threadripper-Sockel.
Das Ding ist halt huge.
Das System lief ja einige Monate und CPU wurde nie aus dem Sockel genommen.
Also wie hätte da auch etwas passieren sollen?
Wir machen jetzt erst mal kurz auf einem anderen Board einen Zwischentest.
Also ich habe ja noch dieses Asus TRX 40 Strix Board bei mir rumliegen, mit dem haben wir schon einige Tests gemacht.
Jetzt die minimale RAM-Konfiguration und da jetzt die CPU draufgepackt.
Ich kann es nun nicht zu lange anlassen, aber ich muss einfach nur checken, ob es über Memory Detector geht.
Erst mal gebrandetes Gehäuse, exquisite.
Ein bisschen die Hand auf die CPU halten.
Sieht aber soweit erstmal gut aus, ist komplett durch RAM durch, B1.
Ja, das sieht gut aus.
Es wurde die CPU relativ warm, solange ich meine Hand draufhalten kann, ist das noch ok.
Das ist mal ein guter Test.
Wird die CPU zu warm, sobald man Finger anfängt zu kochen, ist zu heiß.
92, A2, ok, alles klar.
Damit ist auf jeden Fall die CPU gut.
Das ist schon mal sehr, sehr wichtig.
Das bedeutet, wir haben wahrscheinlich ein defektes Mainboard.
Ich habe mir schon ein Ersatz-Mainboard besorgt.
Das heißt, wir können ganz einfach das Mainboard austauschen.
Und dann sollte das eigentlich alles soweit wieder funktionieren.
Wir müssen natürlich die einzelnen RAM-Sticks nochmal durchtesten, zur Sicherheit.
Aber ich hoffe, das passt dann soweit.
Ich mache dieses Video eigentlich auch deswegen, weil ich euch zeigen möchte,
dass nicht alles immer in dieser Welt der IT-Hardware glatt geht, auch nicht bei mir.
Das ist einfach so.
Man hat öfter mal Pech, auch wenn ein Board oder eine Grafikkarte an sich gut ist.
Man hat eine RMR-Quote von 0,5, 1, 2, 3% bei solchen Artikeln.
Und manchmal ist man halt eben der, der kein Glück hat.
Ja.
In diesem Fall ein bisschen ärgerlich, weil es Mois getroffen hat.
Letzten paar Monate lief es natürlich gut.
Aber schade, wollte wieder anfangen zu streamen.
Hat nicht funktioniert.
Gut, dann werde ich jetzt mal das wieder vorbereiten.
Und wir werden ein neues Board machen.
So.
Schraube, Schraube.
Ist das ein iFixit-Set?
Au!
Okay, er guckt so, als ist was passiert.
Weil der CPU selbst jetzt nicht viel gemacht haben.
Oder?
Gehen die so leicht kaputt?
Weil die haben noch nicht mal Pins unten.
Die haben, die CPUs haben nicht mal Pins unten.
Was soll da großartig kaputt gehen?
Ja.
Au!
Okay.
Okay, ich hatte recht, die CPU hat kein Problem, ja.
Aber das Board.
Ja, RIP.
Das ist schlecht.
Ich glaube, das kriegt man auch nicht so einfach gefixt.
Ehrlich gesagt, keine Ahnung.
Weil...
Da hatte ich noch nie.
Keine Ahnung.
Also, bei den älteren CPUs, die die unten noch Pins hatten.
Da konntest du ohne Probleme die Pins biegen.
Das war kein Problem.
Wie das andersrum ist.
Das sind ja keine Pins mehr.
Das sind eher diese Kontakt-Dinger.
Die quasi bei Kontakt halt Kontakt machen.
Ich hab keine Ahnung, wie es richtig heißt.
Federn, ja.
Das ist, das ist glaube ich nicht so gut.
Ich weiß schon wieder, ja.
Eigentlich sollte ich einfach mit dem Video aufhören.
Ich weiß nicht, was...
Erstmal abmachen, neue dranlöten.
Easy.
Nee, das ist wahrscheinlich im Arsch.
Ich würde sagen.
Ich glaube irgendwie sind die Nasen von diesem Carrier-Frame bei mir abgebrochen.
Weil ich es zu oft rein und raus gemacht habe.
Die Schnausers.
Das hat sich jetzt gerecht.
Ich hoffe die CPU hat nichts abbekommen.
Die CPU sieht soweit aber ganz okay aus.
Also den Rahmen, den hatte ich noch von meinem Epic-Projekt.
Ich weiß gar nicht, warum ich den für diese CPU verwendet hatte.
Aber...
Au!
Großartig.
Es ist Karma, weil ich gerade gesagt habe, es läuft nicht immer alles glatt.
Perfekt.
Gut, das Board ist definitiv für die Tonne.
Weil...
TRX40-Sockel austauschen.
Soweit ich weiß funktioniert das nicht.
Tschüss Board.
Und dann testen wir mal das
neue, komplett bestückte Board.
Ich habe jetzt mal kurz eine CPU-Kühe...
Zum Glück...
Zum Glück ist es der Bauer,
der 5 solcher Boards noch in der Hinterhand im Schrank liegen hat.
Einfach nur, dass die CPU nicht ganz so schnell warm wird.
Weil wir jetzt mehr Memory-Sticks drin haben.
Die ganzen SSDs wieder.
Schauen wir mal...
Was passiert.
Ich hatte jetzt gerade tatsächlich nochmal Probleme,
dass der Rahmen erkannt wird.
Ich habe jetzt mal BIOS-Flashback gemacht.
Ich meine, wir sind die letzten 20 Jahre
schon recht weit gekommen.
Wenn ich mir überlege,
wie damals BIOS-Screens ausgesehen haben
und dass du mit
irgendwelchen kryptischen
DIP-Switch und Jumper-Kombination
Sachen auf deinem Mainboard einstellen musstest
oder resetten musstest
oder irgendwie Geschiss machen musstest,
zu so einem Display, der dir anzeigt,
was Sache ist,
ist schon ein ordentlicher Schritt.
Zumal man ja heute in aktuellen
BIOS-Dingern...
Man hat ja sogar Maus- und Netzwerk-Unterstützung.
Wenn du früher
einen BIOS-Update machen wolltest,
jetzt kommt die Boomer-Zeit
bei mir wieder,
wenn du früher einen BIOS-Update machen wolltest,
da musstest du teilweise noch Disketten machen.
Später geht das mit USB-Sticks.
Aber es ging die ganze Zeit lang
zu Zeiten, wo Disketten gar nicht mehr angesagt waren,
musstest du das über eine Diskette machen.
Aber ist ja auch logisch,
weil im BIOS
halt wirklich nur die allernötigsten Treibersachen
drin sein sollten.
Also man kann sich tatsächlich drüber
streiten, wie sinnvoll das ist
im BIOS.
Okay,
USB-Treiber muss heute sein.
Da muss eine Tastatur über USB dran.
Aber wie sinnvoll es im BIOS ist,
irgendwelche TCP,
Stacks und Netzwerk-Treiber zu haben.
Da kann man sich
echt drüber streiten, ob das
notwendig ist.
USB muss,
weil USB-Tastatur...
Ob ein BIOS eine Maus-Unterstützung
beispielsweise braucht, ist aufraglich.
Ob ein BIOS quasi
Full HD ansteuern können muss, ist aufraglich.
Mal testen.
Das sieht schon besser aus.
Zumindest mal habe ich jetzt die linke
RAM-Bank nur komplett bestückt.
Das sieht soweit eigentlich
nicht ganz gut aus.
Läuft vielleicht ein zweites Mal durch.
Ja, mittlerweile, einen Tag später,
ihr seht,
ich habe jetzt umgeswitcht auf G-Skill-RAM.
Easy, habe ich auch.
Habe ich auch, beste.
Also eigentlich komplett unsinnig,
weil RGB und...
Also, außer ein paar FPS natürlich.
Aber bringt ja nichts
und ist eigentlich unnötig teuer.
Ich weiß nicht, warum ich auch diesen RAM
drinne habe. Wahrscheinlich, weil er mir
Style-mäßig gefallen hat. Was bescheuert ist.
Mein Rechner steht unter dem Schreibtisch.
Ich gucke da nie rein.
Aber es sieht...
Ich habe ja sogar mir Noctua-Lüfterblenden
gekauft, die stylischer aussehen.
Was total bescheuert ist. Ich gucke da nie rein.
Okay, ich habe jetzt auch wieder
das alte Board drauf, weil mit dem neuen
Board gab es auch wieder Probleme, obwohl ich
jeden einzelnen RAM-Stick getestet habe
auf dem anderen System, um zu schauen...
Ja, wasserfreak hat schon jemand gemacht.
Die Sache ist die...
Das wusste ich am Anfang auch nicht, wo
ich es aktiviert habe. Vielleicht sollte ich es
auch mal wieder rausnehmen.
Diese Point-Geschichten,
das funktioniert nicht automatisch.
Das geht nur, wenn ein Mod da ist und das
macht. Das ist zum Beispiel, wie wenn
man hier Time-Out macht.
Time-Out geht auch nur, wenn ein Mod da ist.
Das geht gar nicht automatisch. Ich dachte, das geht automatisch.
Welche Noctua-Lüfter hast du?
Der X-Matsman
hat den NH-D15.
Ich glaube, den habe ich auch.
Stabil laufen.
Das ging. Aber
wenn ich dann die Sticks wieder hier drauf hatte,
dann hatte ich wieder Probleme.
Jetzt testen wir das Ganze mal kurz
mit den G-Skill-Modulen.
Zumindest mal, ob wir hier einen Kaltstart hinbekommen.
G-Skills.
Das sieht auf jeden Fall schon besser aus.
Es ist schon mal CAT-approved.
15 CPU-Code jetzt.
CAT-approved.
Da kann nichts mehr passieren.
Gleich kommt HDD-Detection.
Das sieht jetzt soweit gut aus.
Ich habe das mit 5, 6, 7
Neustarts gemacht. Also Kaltstarts.
Das heißt, komplett Strom weg.
Dann wieder getestet.
Der Chat
sagt, Max hat
den Noctua NH-D15S.
Exquisite.
Chat weiß wieder besser, was für einen CPU-Kühler
ich habe, als ich selbst.
Gucken wir gleich das neue How-to-Twitch-Chat.
Ja, können wir machen. Gute Idee.
Wusste ich gar nicht, dass es Neues gibt.
Ich glaube, ich habe eben keine Grafikkarte gefunden.
Oder keine SSD, die jetzt drauf ist.
Weil hier ist ja an der Seite eigentlich
das DIMM-DATU-Modul verbaut.
Baue ich jetzt mal wieder alles zusammen.
Und dann schauen wir, was passiert.
Jo, damit ist jetzt alles wieder verbaut.
Und geht's?
Postchamp.
Geht's mal ans Testing. Mache ich noch mal so 10 Kaltstarts.
Schauen, ob das funktioniert.
Wenn da Luftblasen drin sind,
das sieht absolut mega aus.
Das sieht man so richtig wie die Strömung
innerhalb von 15 Minuten.
Das ist schon mega, mega cool.
Wie ihr sehen könnt, läuft der PC jetzt endlich.
Das Einzige, was ich gleich noch fixen muss, ist...
Der PC war gar nicht kaputt.
Es war einfach nur das RAM, was es nicht wollte.
Ja gut, kann schon sein.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr es gerade gesehen habt,
aber ich muss auf jeden Fall RGB nochmal neu einstellen.
Entweder muss ich die G-Skill-Software installieren
oder die Armoury Crate.
Muss ich gleich mal probieren.
Oh, RGB ist nicht gesüngt.
Fatal.
Ich bin gespannt, dass wir doch mal ausprobieren können,
wie dieses System versus mein System ist
im Adobe Premiere Rendern.
Deswegen würde ich sagen, wir rendern jetzt mal kurz
mein Testvideo raus und schauen mal,
wie lange das bei diesem System hier dauert.
YouTube typisch natürlich 4K.
Wir haben eine Videolänge von ungefähr 12 Minuten
und dann schauen wir doch mal, wie lange das dauert.
Gedauert hat das Ganze jetzt 7 Minuten 17.
Und dann würde ich sagen, test mal das Gleiche
mal eben auf meinem eigenen PC.
Rennt er das nur über CPU
oder rennt er das auch mit über GPU?
Schauen wir mal, wie lange das hier dauert.
Weil das sieht ganz stark nach CPU Only aus.
Also ich dachte, das ist so ziemlich gleich
von der Performance bisher.
Ich muss dazu aber auch sagen, dass die CPU
gerade bei 4,2 GHz läuft,
also immer noch im Sommer-Overclocking-Modus quasi.
Okay, nicht viel Unterschied.
Das ist tatsächlich ein bisschen langsamer.
Dachte ich eigentlich nicht.
Ich dachte eigentlich, mein System ist
minimal schneller. Es läuft gerade nur bei 4,2.
Ich kann es ja bis auf 4,6 GHz hochtakten.
Klar, dann hole ich die Zeit wieder raus.
Aber dann ist das System halt auch ein bisschen
lauter und braucht mehr Strom.
Und dann denke ich mir so,
die 15 Sekunden sind mir immer...
Scheiß drauf, ja.
Da muss man einfach sagen, Projekt Unvernunft
war damals ein korrekt
gewählter Name, weil meine CPU quasi
zu viel kostet. Die kostet ja glaube ich 1.800.
Der 32 Kern-AMD
fällt über. Und meine CPU
damals 3.400.
Aha, 3000 Euro CPU.
Muss man schon sagen, die AMD fällt über.
Die CPUs sind halt einfach preisleistungstechnisch
sehr, sehr gut. Wobei die CPU damals
glaube ich noch nicht auf dem Markt war, muss ich dazu auch sagen.
Die kam kurz danach raus, aber
als ich es gekauft habe, gab es sie ja noch nicht.
Sind schon sehr, sehr gut. Muss man einfach
zugeben. Damit bedanke ich mich auch schon
fürs Zuschauen. Wir sehen uns beim nächsten Mal.
Bis dann.
So, was war jetzt das neue
How to Twitch Chat?
Gibt es da was
Neues?
How to Twitch Chat,
weil die letzten haben eigentlich alle geguckt.
PogChannel, das kennen wir schon.
Ah,
How to Twitch Chat Gatschi
Edition. Oh.
Okay, das
müssen wir uns jetzt angucken.
Oh...
Oh oh...
Ich konnte ihn gar nicht bezeichnen. Du hast mich in die Seelenglass-Klasse geschmissen und ich war im Krankenhaus.
Hey, was machst du?
Oh Gott, sorry, dass ich das hören kann, Mr. Prime. Wir werden euch alle in der Halle in der Klasse vermissen.
Habt einen schönen Tag.
Heute werden wir über die Gatchi-Emojis kümmern und wie sie eine der meisten eikonischen Emojis in Twitch-Chat verwendet wurden.
Aber zuerst ein kleines Historie-Lesson, wie Gatchi in der ersten Stelle populär wurde.
Und dann auf YouTube hochgeladen und das war halt voll in diesen Kreisen. Ich weiß nicht, ob es 4chan war oder so.
Irgendjemand hat quasi Video-Animationen mit dem Typ drin erstellt.
Und irgendwie hat es dann seinen Weg über den Forsen-Chat gefunden auf das restliche Twitch.
Irgendwie soweit ich weiß. Und der Typ heißt gar nicht Anarchy oder so. Der heißt irgendwie anders.
Aber irgendwie sagen alle Anarchy oder Any-Key oder so. So viel zu meiner Twitch-History-Geschichte, was ich dazu weiß.
Video ist leise. Okay, wartet mal.
Ein bisschen lauter machen.
So, ha?
Hyper Gatchi.
Das Internet.
Das muss man sich jetzt mal auf der Zunge zergehen lassen, was die da für ein Video erstellt haben. Hört sich mal an.
Was?
Jetzt wissen wir Bescheid.
Alles klar.
Der war der Beste.
What? Was? Hä? Von was spricht er?
Oh mein Gott.
Was ist das für ein Scheiß-Gift? Ist ja geil.
Was ist das für ein Scheiß-Gift, Alter?
Okay, das verwende ich nie. Jetzt habe ich ihn noch nicht mal aktiviert.
Nur?
Hier lernst du noch was.
Jetzt wird nicht zensiert, oder was?
Was ist hier? Wir lassen uns Twitch Emotes erklären.
Portdialog, Alter. Portdialog, Alter.
Der macht echt coole Videos, der Chip. Vor allem ist das ja auch inhaltlich noch gut, wenn man sich für Twitch Emotes interessiert.
Wunder mich, dass es kaum Leute gucken, guck mal. Normalerweise, normalerweise müsste sowas 50k Views haben.
Oh Mann. So, was haben wir sonst noch zum angucken? Also das haben wir schon hier durch. Spiele im Oktober juckt mich jetzt nicht so sehr.
Sketchy Aliexpress cooler. Was machen sie? Irgendetwas langweiliges, oder? Das ist glaube ich nicht so spannend.
Der Setup Box für den Raspberry Pi ist auch nicht so spannend.
Ich frage mich, wo der Sinn ist von diesen ganzen Raspberry Pi Gehäuse. Jetzt ernsthaft, wozu überhaupt so ein Gehäuse?
Warum nicht einfach den Raspberry Pi nehmen wie er ist und hinstellen? Das ist ja nicht so, als könnte da großartig was passieren.
Ich weiß gar nicht, warum man da so riesenfette Gehäuse drum bauen sollte.
Tommi fragt, Max kennst du das? Was? Max kennst du das? Man hat ein großes Projekt, dann schließt sich ein Bug erstmal beiseite zu legen und nicht zu verfolgen.
Dann setzt man sich dran, debuggt seit fucking 40 Stunden finden. Das verändere ich den Fehler. Ja, 40 Stunden Debuggen ist hart.
Gatschi Hyper. Also bei mir ist es meistens so, wenn ich Sachen nicht finde, ich probiere das dann meistens einen Tag später.
Und wenn man eine Runde gepennt hat, findet man so Sachen dann ganz spontan nach dem Aufstimmen. Achso, daran liegt es.
So, Raspberry Pi Gehäuse, egal. Lego Tank, juckt mich jetzt auch nicht. Game in ein QR-Code.
Oder 20 Minuten, das ist grad zu lang. Flappy Bird, Netflix. Das haben wir das letzte Mal schon geguckt, das war Fake-Rack.
Das war so ein Rack, was sie nur haben, dass es gut ausschaut, also hat nichts mit der Realität zu tun.
Ziemlich Resident Sleeper, ok, hab ich halt geguckt. Der hat 257 Euro Warzone Budget Gaming PC, ok. Home Office und Server.
All ultimativ. IGIT! Das ist dieses Gehäuse. Kommt euch dieses Gehäuse irgendwie bekannt vor, Leute? Kommt euch dieses Gehäuse irgendwie bekannt vor?
Oder davon abgesehen, dass es hier auf einem Haufen Amazon-Verpackungsmüll steht. Kommt euch das irgendwie bekannt vor?
Diese XP, wieso, das ist der beste. Deswegen, ich hab den extra gemacht, weil es der Windows XP Hintergrund ist.
Ok, das müssen wir uns jetzt, wir gucken uns das mal im Schnelldurchgang an, weil 28 Minuten, mal gucken, ob das Video was taugt.
Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu diesem neuen Video. Heute zeige ich euch, wie ihr euren eigenen günstigen, stromsparenden und gleichzeitig leistungsstarken Home Server selber bauen könnt.
So ganz einfach. Einfach bauen. Dabei zeige ich euch in diesem Video, welche Komponenten ihr dafür benötigt, wie ihr diese so auswählt, dass sie harmonieren und auch gut funktionieren.
Und ich zeige euch auch, wie ihr die ganzen Komponenten dann hier in ein solches neuestes Servergehäuse einbaut. Aber auch wie ihr das Ganze mit einem ganz normalen PC Powergehäuse machen könnt.
Zum Schluss installieren wir dann auf unserem Server noch BoxMox als Virtualisierungssystem, sodass ihr dann damit verschiedenste virtuelle Maschinen oder Linux-Container...
Also auf 1,75 ist gut.
Also, wie ihr seht, wir haben hier ganz schön was zu tun. Deshalb würde ich sagen, legen wir doch direkt los.
Du möchtest dir deinen eigenen Server zusammenstellen oder gebrauchten Komponenten einen solchen Home Server zusammenstellen.
Der Sound hört sich einfach verkehrt an.
Wir möchten hier neue Komponenten verwenden, möchten das Ganze leistungsstark, aber gleichzeitig auch möglichst stromsparend gestalten und auch so, dass dieser Home Server wirklich lange Bestand hat, dass wir den lange im ganz normalen...
Okay, also was kommt rein? Wir skippen jetzt mal ein bisschen was.
Das gleiche hässliche Gehäuse, was ich auch habe. Okay, der einzige Grund, warum ich dieses Gehäuse genommen habe, ist, weil es das einzige billige 19 Zoll Rack-Gehäuse war, was lieferbar war.
Das ist noch so ein bisschen so ein Nischenmarkt, irgendwie da gibt es zu wenig.
Wenn man nämlich mal bei Geizhals guckt...
Äh, wo sind denn Gehäuse?
Hardware, Hardware, Gehäuse. So, und wenn man jetzt hier mal filtert nach...
19 Zoll Gehäuse, das Zeug ist viel zu teuer.
Und es gibt wenige wirklich billige Gehäuse oder günstige Gehäuse.
Und das einzige günstige, was ist teilweise so, im Angebot, teilweise so um die 40 Euro, ist halt dieses Ding hier.
Und das ist richtig, das ist eigentlich mega schlecht, dieses Gehäuse.
Erleicht guckt halt schon mal diese komische Lüfte an, das ist das erste, was du raus machen musst.
Und auch dieser Wechselrahmen ist übelst billiger Crap, ja.
Aber es lohnt sich nicht, da lohnt es sich fast schon mehr, einen gebrauchten Server auf Ebay zu kaufen und alles rauszuschmeißen, bis auf das Gehäuse.
Das ist billiger, also du kriegst für den Preis einen gebrauchten Server auf Ebay, kein Problem.
Einfach selber was 3D drucken, genau.
Daily Use und vor allen Dingen natürlich auch 247 betreiben könnt.
Ich habe mir aber auch als Ziel gesetzt, dass dieser Home Server mit allen Komponenten, die ich dafür brauche, nicht mehr als 500 Euro kosten darf.
Okay, das ist ordentlich, 500 ist wirklich ein ausgiebiges Budget.
Und das habe ich auch gut geschafft.
Welche Komponenten ihr dafür auswählen müsst, seht ihr dann hier.
Und das habe ich auch gut geschafft. Welche Komponenten ihr dafür auswählen müsst, seht ihr dann hier.
Was bin ich der einzige bei dem, wenn er redet es rauscht? Echt, ich rausche? Wirklich? Rausche ich? Seit wann rausche ich denn?
Echt, ich rausche? Wirklich? Hab ich irgendwie Mist eingestellt? Jetzt muss ich mir mal kurz anhören.
Jetzt muss ich mir mal kurz anhören.
Aber sonst rauscht es nicht, oder?
Weil ansonst, ansonsten rauscht es nicht.
Ja gut, das ist, das ist nur rauscht, wenn ich rede, ist klar.
War, oh, oh, ah. Moment. Bei den, ah, haha.
Ich glaube Teams war wieder am Start. Ich glaube Teams hat wieder reingehauen.
Ah, yes.
So, jetzt ist besser, ne?
Teams, Teams hat es verkackt.
Das geht mir so auf den Sack, Teams, ne? Dass es immer an meinen, an meinen Audio-Settings rumstellt.
Voll für'n Arsch, oder? Mega, mega für'n Arsch.
Muss ich mir gar nicht anhören.
Ja, macht immer nicht so laute Intros.
Als kleine Orientierung für euch, damit ihr anschauen könnt, was ihr dann mit einem, ja, solchen Home-Server mit...
Ja, dann erzähl mal, was lässt da auf deinem Home-Server laufen?
Da bin, da bin ich ja mal gespannt, ob da jetzt irgendwas Sinnvolles dabei ist.
Wo ich sag, hey, da hab ich nicht dran gedacht.
Mal, meine Anwendungsfälle, die ich damit abdecken möchte.
Nun, zum einen möchte ich da drauf natürlich...
Ja, hab ich auch laufen, aber will ich nicht mehr haben.
Meine Nextcloud zu Hause hosten, das sollte kein grosseres Problem sein mit dem, was ich hierfür ausgewählt hab.
Ich möchte damit aber auch meine VPN betreiben.
Nextcloud kann man machen.
Wobei das ein bisschen schwierig ist, mit VPN drauf laufen zu lassen, je nachdem, wo man's stehen hat.
Weil Nextcloud zum größten Teil unfertiger Krämpel ist.
Das Einzige, was an Nextcloud sinnvoll ist, ist der, also das, was gut funktioniert, ist das eingebaute, der eingebaute Calcuttaf-Server.
Den kann man aber auch brauchen, aber auch kein Nextcloud für.
Ähm, ja, und den Filesync, da bin ich mir noch unschlüssig, durch was ich den ersetze.
Übrigens, das mit VPN ist ziemlich schwierig, ne?
Je nachdem, wie er das machen will.
Weil, also, ich muss mal, zumindest, zumindest, wie ich das bei mir gemacht hab, ist so.
Die Kiste steht intern bei mir, im ganz normalen internen Netz.
Allerdings, das interne Netz ist dafür gedacht, dass ich da jetzt nicht irgendwie noch VPN von extern reinmachen kann.
Also, ich mein, ich könnte sicherlich dort irgendwelche Sachen weiterleiten, aber...
Das ist gar nicht Sinn und Zweck der Sache, also...
Für mich würde beispielsweise für VPN...
...den Raspberry Pi hinter der Fritzbox oder hinter dem Router mehr Sinn machen.
Äh, ne, ne, Nextcloud, wenn man das für Filesync und Kontakte und so verwendet, ist es schon okay.
Aber, die ganzen Nextcloud-Apps sind halt teilweise echt hart, unfertig und vor allem unpolished.
Das fängt schon an, dass du ne To-Do- und ne Notizen-App hast, wo du die Sachen nicht richtig durchsuchen kannst.
Wo man sich halt denkt, okay, wofür brauch ich ne Notizen-App?
Und dann ist es schon okay.
Wenn du ne Notizen-App hast, wo du die Sachen nicht richtig durchsuchen kannst. Wo man sich halt denkt, okay, wofür brauch ich ne Notizen-App, wenn die Suche nicht funktioniert.
Es macht an vielen Stellen einfach einen komplett unfertigen Eindruck.
...ein NAS betreiben, deswegen seht ihr auch hier die NAS-Festplatten.
Ich hab zwar schon Synology NAS bei mir zu Hause stehen, das nutze ich aber nicht...
Okay, wir machen mal ein bisschen, wir gucken erstmal was an.
Also, was will er noch draufbauen?
Nextcloud, IPSec, VPN, okay.
NAS, gut, irgendeinen Fallsauber drauf.
UniFi-Controller, NVR ist das für die UniFi-Kameras.
Ja, UniFi-Controller hab ich witzigerweise nicht bei mir auf der Kiste hier mit drauf, sondern das läuft wirklich auf dem Raspberry Pi, der unten im Wohnzimmer neben dem Access Point steht.
Das Gute an dem Access Point ist, mit dem funktioniert es nämlich noch ganz gut.
Weil, der hat zwei Anschlüsse.
Und zwar, ich hoffe man sieht das von unten.
Genau, hier muss man PoE dran machen.
Hier macht man PoE dran.
Also sprich PoE, dass der Access Point läuft.
Und hier in der Mitte kann man noch einen Raspberry Pi anschließen, über USB und an den zweiten Netzwerk-Port.
Also, ich finde die Kombi ist eigentlich wirklich ganz praktisch, weil du brauchst außer PoE sonst nichts mehr.
PoE ist Strom über das Netzwerk-Kabel.
Also, du kannst quasi das Ding hier per PoE versorgen und den Raspberry stöpselst du einfach hier dran.
Und dann hast du so eine Kombi, die gut funktioniert und du halt keine weiteren Kabels brauchst.
Deswegen hab ich den UniFi-Access Point auf einem Raspberry Pi laufen.
Das ist aber auch ein extra Netz.
Also sprich, das ist bei mir auch nicht im internen Netz drin.
Sondern ich hab, WLAN ist bei mir WLAN 1337 und WLAN, ich glaub sogar 1, default.
Und zumindest so ist es standardmäßig, glaub ich, auch eingerichtet, dass WLAN 1 quasi hier das Management WLAN ist bei UniFi.
Und da hab ich den Raspberry Pi auch dran.
Dann brauch ich auch kein zweites Kabel mehr ins Erdgeschoss machen irgendwie für einen Raspberry Pi oder so.
Das hat sich ganz gut angeboten.
Deswegen den UniFi-Controller würde ich da gar nicht drauf machen.
Zumal, wie gesagt, die Kiste bei mir auch intern steht und intern und WLAN passt irgendwie nicht.
Also, wie gesagt, meine Kiste steht halt komplett intern und da würde weder VPN drauf passen, noch UniFi-Controller,
weil das eine ist im WLAN und das andere müsste ja quasi Portweiterleitung vom Internet aus sein.
Und ich hab's halt so strukturiert bei mir, das wirklich internes Netz ist auch wirklich reines internes Netz.
Da kommt nix rein von außen. Da wird nix freigeschaltet.
Ausnahmen bestätigen die Regel.
Hab ich wieder abgeschafft, weil Twitch und YouTube nicht mal gut damit funktioniert.
Okay, das passt. Das klingt sinnvoll.
Was hat er denn hier für ein Board?
Was ist für ein Board? Ah, das ist irgendwas für ein i3. Okay, das ist kein Single, also kein mit CPU drauf.
Und der letzte Grund, wieso ich mich für dieses Mainboard entschieden hab, ist,
dass ich zudem hier auch noch eine NVMe SSD direkt auf dem Board verbauen kann.
Ist gut.
Ja, das ist irgendein normales... Ich weiß, wie heißen die aktuellen Intel-Sockel nochmal?
Also das ist kein Ultra-Low-End-Ultra-Power-Board.
Das heißt, damit hast du schon ordentlich Wumms mit der CPU drauf und dem Unterbau.
Da hast du auch ordentlich PCI-Express-Lanes und alles.
Da musst du dir keine Gedanken drüber machen, dass du irgendwo Beschränkungen hast.
Es ist auf jeden Fall deutlich leistungsfähiger als das, was ich drin hab.
...direkt auf dem Board verbauen kann. Gekostet hat mich dieses Mainboard hier circa 110 Euro.
Wenn das Mainboard teurer ist als die CPU...
Als nächstes zum Prozessor. Wie gesagt, ich hab hier...
Da wobei, bei dem, doch, der kann sogar mehr kosten.
...war ein Intel-Prozessor entschieden, und zwar einen i3-Prozessor der 8. Generation mit 4 x 3,6 GHz.
Nun, wieso jetzt ein i3 und nicht ein i5 oder i7?
Nun, das hat ganz einfach den Grund, hier wollte ich mich wirklich an dieser Prämisse stromsparat orientieren
und gerade mit dem i3 3,6 GHz reicht...
Das teuerste werden wahrscheinlich die Festplatten, je nachdem, was das für welche sind.
...die Anwendungen, die ich abbilden möchte, vollkommen aus.
Das ist alles nicht sehr anspruchsvoll für den...
Der Prozessor hat...
Ja, ich sag doch, wenn die CPU billiger ist als das Mainboard.
...94 Euro...
Noch Tourlüfter, okay. Jetzt will er es aber wissen, ja.
...26 Euro, also 26 Euro, und das sollte dann mein...
Das ist überhaupt eine NVMe, ist das D?
Hat das Board überhaupt NVMe, so Billigboards? Die haben ja gerne mal nur SATA auf M2.
Das sind das die Noctua NF-A625...
Äh, M2 auf SATA, oder wie auch immer.
...pro Stück circa 13 Euro, also 26 Euro, und das sollte dann mein...
Nur eine SATA, macht aber eigentlich auch... ja, macht aber eigentlich keinen Unterschied, ob SATA oder NVMe jetzt.
Also klar, NVMe ist schon besser und schneller und doller und mehr BigBrain, aber...
So unterm Strich wird es wahrscheinlich bei diesem Low-End-Ding nicht so allzu viel Unterschied machen.
Schön leise machen...
Den Zusammenbau... weiß nicht, ob ich es jetzt angucken muss.
...beziehungsweise außerhalb des Servers...
Loslegen...
32G ist schon ordentlich, aber aktuell ist RAM so billig, das würde ich auch machen.
Lohnt sich in der Preisklasse nicht viel mehr ein Ryzen.
Kommt darauf an, also gerade im Ultra... wie soll man sagen...
Low-Segment, was auch Low-Power ist, ist Intel noch ein bisschen besser.
Bei den CPUs, muss ich ehrlich sagen, weiß ich nicht, aber Intel hat ja auch ihre...
...Ultra-Low-Power-Serie.
Also das, was Jiminy Lake war und jetzt Elkhart Lake wirkt, wird und sowas.
Da ist Intel noch ein bisschen Stromsparender.
...dass er auch wirklich fest sitzt.
Sieht aber gut aus, also viele haben ja Angst...
Gut, er macht hier nicht den Bauer und haut das Ding auf den Sockel drauf.
...CPU montieren ist aber eigentlich gar nicht so schlimm, finde ich.
Ja, dann machen wir das Ganze wieder zu.
Schauen, dass das auch hier unter die Schraube kommt.
Und dann können wir das mit etwas Druck hier andrücken.
Oh, man sieht schon, also...
CPU einbauen kann gefährlich sein.
...und wieder einlegen.
So, das Ganze sollte jetzt schon mal...
Man hört auch, das rastet ein.
Ja, das sind so die Standard-Interlüfter.
Die sind immer...
Ja.
Exquisite.
Gut, das müssen wir uns jetzt nicht weiter angucken.
Iiih, diese...
Leute, das ist exakt das Gehäuse, was wir hier haben.
Das ist exakt das Gehäuse, was ich auch habe.
Das Gehäuse ist wirklich Müll.
Ich habe das einzige Grund, warum ich dieses Gehäuse genommen habe, ist...
...weil es das einzig erschwingbare 19 Zoll Gehäuse war...
...wo die Sachen reingepasst haben, die ich reinbauen will.
Das ist der einzige Grund.
Ansonsten ist das Gehäuse, finde ich, totaler Müll.
Leider gibt es da nicht so viele Alternativen zu.
Was auch Müll ist...
...dass der Wechselrahmen für die Festplatten mit der billigsten Backplane, die ich je gesehen habe...
...dass es so fett ist, dass du hier nur wirklich sehr kleine PCI-Expresskarten reinkriegst.
Also das müssen schon wirklich...
...nicht nur Low Profile, das müssen auch Low Profile und Low-Tief-Karten sein.
Wobei, ich glaube, Low Profile müssen es doch nicht mal sein.
Also hier passen wirklich nur die allerkürzesten PCI-Expresskarten rein.
Meine normale 10G-Netzwerkkarte hat hier hinten nicht reingepasst.
Deswegen habe ich die auf die andere Seite gesteckt.
Guck mal, das ist genau das gleiche Gehäuse.
Hier sind eigentlich die PCI-Express-Anschlüsse.
Und die Netzwerkkarte war zwei Zentimeter zu lang.
Und ich habe die einfach hier auf die Seite gesteckt.
Man sieht es hier ganz gut auf der Seite, wo das Netzteil eigentlich reinkommt.
Da kann man hier die Schraube ein bisschen abmachen...
...und kann die Netzwerkkarte dazwischenklemmen.
Ich kann mal ein bisschen heranzoomen.
Ich habe jetzt einfach die Netzwerkkarte genommen...
...hab die auf der einen Seite an den PS2-Sockel geklemmt...
...und auf der anderen Seite die Schraube ein bisschen aufgemacht und ins Gehäuse geklemmt.
Das Ding ist bombenfest, da kannst du nichts sagen.
Aber es hält.
Das einzige Dumme ist, man braucht ein längeres PCI-Express-Kabel, dass das funktioniert.
Allerdings braucht man hier auch ein PCI-Express-Kabel, weil es geht halt nicht anders.
Aber es funktioniert echt gut.
Kann man nichts sagen, es funktioniert exquisite.
Und ich habe hier drüben genug Platz gehabt für USB und nochmal USB.
Ach ja und hier oben, wer sich fragt, wo das Loch im Gehäuse herkommt...
Also das ist nicht normal, dass hier ein Loch ist im Gehäuse.
Ich habe zuerst versucht, die Netzwerkkarte hier oben drauf zu setzen.
Weil es hätte gerade so gepasst von der Höhe her.
Aber ich habe da nichts gefunden, wo man die ordentlich festmachen kann.
Deswegen habe ich die Netzwerkkarte hier eben hingesetzt.
Das war das Loch für die Netzwerkkarte, dass da ein Stecker reinpasst.
Abenteuerliches Ding.
So, ja weiter.
Die sind Müll, die sind ultra Müll.
Das erste, was ich rausgebaut habe, ist diese komischen Kacklüfter, die dabei waren.
Richtig, richtiger Müll die Lüfter.
Ah yes, Excellent Noctua Lüfter.
Ja, das habe ich mir auch überlegt, ob ich mir so ein komisches Netzteil holen soll.
Aber wie gesagt, an der Stelle muss die Netzwerkkarte hin.
Und ich habe hier so eine Pico PSU.
Das heißt, das sieht dann zwar nicht so schön aus, aber man sieht es ehrlich gesagt kaum.
Also es fällt kaum auf.
Da unten ist ein bisschen frei, wo das Kabel vom Netzteil rausgeht.
Aber das fällt kaum auf, das ist nicht wirklich wild.
Ja, ja.
Software Installationen müssen wir uns nicht angucken.
Was macht der dann drauf?
Proxmox.
Warum stehen alle so auf Proxmox?
Verabschiedung.
Excellent.
Warum stehen alle so auf Proxmox?
Ich habe das auch mal ausprobiert.
Das ist okay, aber ich weiß nicht, wozu ich es großartig brauche.
Weil Proxmox ist eher so in Richtung ESX in diese Richtung.
Halt reine Virtualisierungsgeschichte mit Management Interface.
Man kann darauf zwar Container laufen lassen, aber keine normalen Docker Container,
was es eh schon ein bisschen schwieriger macht für fertiges Zeug, was er sonst für Videos macht.
Können wir mal gucken.
Hallo.
Ja, also ich habe jetzt für mich den großartigen Mehrwert bei Proxmox noch nicht erkannt.
Ich sage nicht, dass es schlecht ist.
An sich ist es ein gutes Produkt, was auch gut funktioniert.
Aber ich habe, wie gesagt, für mich den großartigen Mehrwert noch nicht erkannt.
Aber ich bin halt mittlerweile eh auf dem Standpunkt, ich mache es so einfach wie möglich
und so wenig Zwischendinger wie möglich, dass ich noch durchblicke, was ich getrieben habe.
Für mich heißt das im Endeffekt, ich klatsche einen Ubuntu Server oder irgendwas Linux-mäßiges drauf,
installiere die paar Sachen, die ich brauche und gut ist.
Für jemanden, der jetzt vielleicht nicht jeden Tag Linux-Geschichten macht,
ist es vielleicht mit Proxmox wirklich einfacher, wenn man das darüber managen kann.
Aber wie gesagt, ich habe nicht eine VM laufen auf der Kiste.
Ich habe einen Docker Compose-File, das startet irgendwie 7-8 Containers mit allem, was ich brauche und fertig.
Und das ist wirklich so easy mittlerweile.
Und wenn man auch die Tags nicht auf Latest setzt, auch relativ stable,
bis auf einmal, wo ich nicht aufgepasst hatte, wo mein Doku-Wiki-Latest-Tag noch hatte, wo es mal kaputt gegangen ist,
läuft es jetzt seit irgendwie einem Jahr oder so ohne jegliche Probleme,
holt sich immer neue Let's Encrypt-Zertifikate, passt immer alles.
Ich meine, der Kram hier läuft ja auch drauf.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich euch heute schon mal meine Heizungssteuerung, meine Heizungsüberwachung gezeigt habe.
Das Zertifikat, das wird ja auch ausgestellt automatisch darüber.
Festplatte durchreichen in Proxmox. Exquisite.
Engine X Proxy Manager. Den finde ich tatsächlich nicht verkehrt, den Engine X Proxy Manager.
Mal gucken, ob der das Web-Interface drin hat. Da kann ich euch mal kurz zeigen, wie das aussieht.
Hat er das Web-Interface drin?
Genau. Der Engine X Proxy Manager ist eigentlich eine ganz coole Sache.
Also für jemand, der beispielsweise einen...
Angenommen jemand hat sich ein Domain gekauft und er möchte jetzt entweder intern oder vielleicht sogar echte...
Stellt euch vor, ihr habt euch pepo-fat.com gekauft und wollt dann einen Minecraft-Server bei euch daheim laufen lassen.
Ganz billig gesagt.
Da wollt ihr den Minecraft-Server vielleicht nicht direkt im Internet exposen oder wie auch immer.
Das heißt, ihr wollt erstmal einen Proxy mit eventuell Authentifizierung davor machen.
Und das Ding sollte auch gültige Zertifikate haben.
Dafür ist quasi der Engine X Proxy Manager ziemlich gut.
Warum ich den Engine X Proxy Manager nicht mag, liegt daran, man kann keine Let's Encrypt-Zertifikate mit DNS-Authentifizierung machen.
Was für mich schon K.O.-Kriterium ist, weil meine ganze Zertifikate gehen über DNS-Challenge.
Weil DNS-Challenge das einfachste ist, wenn man Domain intern verwendet.
Bei mir gehen... Die Domain ist bei Cloudflare auf dem DNS-Server, kommt das Ganze raus.
Und du kannst bei Cloudflare über die API die DNS-Challenge für Let's Encrypt hinterlegen.
Das heißt, ohne DNS-Challenge kann ich gar keine Zertifikate ausstellen lassen.
Also sprich, ohne DNS-Challenge hätte das Ding hier kein gültiges Zertifikat.
Und deswegen kann ich es nicht mit Engine X Proxy Manager machen, muss ich aber auch nicht.
Das macht das alles mehr oder weniger automatisch.
Ja, aber das Video... Man muss sagen, also der Bauvorschlag an sich, den finde ich nicht übel.
Kann man so machen.
Warum nicht?
Ansonsten scheint das alles auch schon Hand und Fuß zu haben hier.
Ja, das ist Traffic, wobei ich Traffic auch nicht wirklich mag, weil Traffic die Config...
Also wenn man mit... Also ich rede von diesem Ding hier.
Das ist ein Loadbalancer bzw. Loadbalancer-Reverse-Proxy, der halt besonders gute Docker-Unterstützung hat.
Warum sieht dein YouTube so komisch aus?
Ach ne, du meinst nicht mein YouTube, du meinst das YouTube hier.
Wieso, was sieht daran komisch aus? Ich hab Darkseam, ansonsten hab ich nix.
Ach so, ich hab ein bisschen rangezoomt. Guck mal, wenn ich... So sieht das bei dir aus, ne?
Ja, aber wenn du ein bisschen ranzoomst, dann denkt YouTube, oh, wir sind auf mobile und...
Ja, macht das mobile-mäßig.
Ja, aber wo war ich jetzt gerade stehen geblieben?
Also warum ich Traffic nicht mag? Traffic ist ein Reverse-Proxy bzw. Loadbalancer für...
Hauptsächlich für Container-Geschichten, weil alles andere ist eklig.
Also es ist... Es wird nicht explizit vermarktet für Container-Only.
Also du kannst mit Traffic alles Reverse-Proxying und alles Loadbalancen, aber die Config ist voll für'n Arsch.
EasyLite, genau. Die Config ist voll für'n Arsch.
Das einzige Gute ist, wenn man rein Container-Reverse-Proxying will, dann ist es einfach,
weil das kann man komplett in seinem Config-File, also in der YAML-Config direkt mitmachen.
Aber möchte man weitere Sachen Loadbalancen, ist es wirklich scheiße.
Deswegen gefällt mir auch nicht wirklich, aber es gibt gerade nichts anderes,
was ähnlich umfangreich ist und gut funktioniert in dem Setup, was ich hab.
Was nimmt man für Nicht-Container?
Nginx mag ich ehrlich gesagt am liebsten. Oder wenn's ganz einfach sein soll, dann den hier.
Also die einfachste Sache ist wirklich das hier.
Der Traffic macht Let's Encrypt komplett mit.
Also die einfachste Web-Server-Reverse-Proxy-Geschichte ist das hier. Einfacher geht's nicht.
Getting Started, ich weiß nicht, ob die einen Example haben.
Nein, nein, nein, nein.
Hier.
Also das ist alles, was wir für einen...
Muss man sich mal angucken, die haben die Config ein bisschen komplizierter gemacht mit Version 2 irgendwie.
Genau, das ist alles, was man für ein Reverse-Proxy braucht.
Also Cuddy ist, oder das hier als Config-File, Cuddy ist mit Abstand der einfachste.
Aber ich nehm normalerweise immer Nginx, weil ich mich da schon dran gewöhnt hab.
Aber Cuddy ist top.
Leider jetzt, wenn man viele Containers intern hat, ist es mit Traffic doch noch ein Ticken einfacher zu konfigurieren.
Ich hoffe aber, die kommen dahin.
Weil Traffic-Config ist wirklich kacke.
Aber yeah, easy, Leute, das macht mein Let's Encrypt mit.
Das hat ein Plugin für Cloudflare.
Und dem Cloudflare-Plugin gibt man einfach seine AP-Credentials und dann macht er DNS-Challenge.
Die haben sogar mal einen Stream gemacht, wo ich das nachgebaut hab hier.
So, was können wir uns jetzt angucken?
Hast du Venis Unleashed für Battlefield 3 gesehen?
Ja, da bin ich sehr gespannt drauf.
Okay, dann gucken wir uns jetzt den 256, äh, 57 Call of Duty Warzone-Rechner an.
Bin mal gespannt, was da rauskommt.
Ähm, ich mein...
Machbar ist das sicherlich.
Ich könnte mir vorstellen, wenn man 250...
Ich bin ja kein Fan.
Ich bin ja kein Fan von 200...
Äh, von 257 Euro, nein.
Ich bin ja kein Fan von gebrauchten Rechnern.
Aber ich könnte mir vorstellen, wenn man wirklich ein richtiges Budget...
Richtiges Budget...
Low...
End...
Gaming-Rechner bauen will...
Dann könnte ich mir vorstellen, fährt man gar nicht so schlecht, wenn man sich gebrauchte Sachen auf Ebay kauft.
Weil gerade CPU-Leistung ist in den letzten Jahren nicht so extrem explodiert.
Ich rede jetzt nicht von Multicore und sonst was.
Klar, heute kriegst du 12 Kerne.
Billiger wie nie zuvor.
Aber wenn man das auf Gaming-Sachen bezieht...
Ich kann mir auch ohne Probleme einen 4-Kerner oder sonst was...
Oder vielleicht sogar 6-8-Kerner, wie auch immer...
Von vor ein paar Jahren auf Ebay kaufen.
Der ist gar nicht so viel schlechter, wie ein aktueller.
Also ich könnte mir vorstellen, wenn man sich wirklich einen super Budget-Gaming-Rechner bauen will...
Dann ist gebrauchte Sachen auf Ebay kaufen gar nicht verkehrt.
Okay, guck mal, was da rauskommt.
Dann müsste man aus dem Keller...
Nee, warum? Man kann sich das bei Ebay ja schicken lassen.
Heute gibt's mal wieder einen typischen Gaming-Build von mir.
Die ist mal vielleicht so mit dem Thema Modern Warfare Fortnite.
Also ein paar Spielchen.
Vielleicht auch noch der Flight-Simulator.
Ich schau mal, ob ich das noch aufbringen kann, diese 150 Gigabyte oder was das da sind.
Noch zeitig runterzuladen, damit es noch zum Video passt.
Ja.
Dann fangen wir an, ich zeig euch die Teile.
Und da sind auch schon die Teile.
Das gehen wir mal eben schnell durch.
Wir beginnen am besten mal hier mit.
Eine Action-LED-Leiste für 6 Euro.
Muss.
Natürlich.
Wo kommt man da hin ohne LED-Leiste?
6,50 Euro, irgendwas in dem Bereich.
Mit Fernbedienung, USB-Anschluss müssen wir später noch umlöten.
Wir können aber auch einen Adapter nehmen oder das hinten einfach anschließen.
Die verwende ich ja ziemlich oft in meinem Bild.
Also da sieht man wieder, die beste Investition für einen Gaming-Rechner ist nicht etwa eine bessere Grafikkarte, sondern RGB.
Also es gibt nichts besseres als RGB, preisleistungsmäßig und Leistungssteigerung.
Also für so wenig Geld bekommt man bei nichts anderem mehr Leistung als bei RGB.
Dann haben wir hier eine 240 Gigabyte SSD von Western Digital.
Die habe ich tatsächlich neu gekauft.
Und die Preise, die werde ich später einmal zeigen.
Ich habe sie nämlich gerade nicht im Kopf, aber ich habe eine Quittung von allem.
Schönes Netzteil.
Als Netzteil verwenden wir hier einen Be Quiet Pure Power 530 Watt.
Grafikkarte ist eine AMD RX 570 Nitro mit 4 Gigabyte.
Und als Prozessor haben wir einen Ryzen 5600 auf einem MSI A320M mit 16 Gigabyte RAM.
Ich muss dazu sagen, das Mainboard...
Stimmt, da passt Warsaw nicht drauf, das ist zu groß.
Den Prozessor habe ich tatsächlich von einem Zuschauer gekauft,
der mich dann erkannt hat.
Das passiert immer mal wieder.
Und dieses Gehäuse hatten wir ja in ähnlicher Ausführung im letzten Eintrag ein Gaming-PC-Video.
Allerdings waren das dann hier so Gitter, wenn ich mich recht...
Okay, da macht auch eBay Einkauf.
... dürften, glaube ich, grün oder blau beleuchtet sein.
Ich weiß es nicht mehr, ich meine, ich habe dafür vielleicht 20 Euro bezahlt.
Wenn ich die Modelle noch mal finde dazu, dann werde ich sie hier noch mal einblenden.
Easy Light, warum? Was ist so schlimm, wenn man das auf die Folie außen legt?
Wenn ich jetzt alles zusammenbaue, teste ich mal eben das Mainboard mit der Grafikkarte und so weiter,
ob das hochfährt, das habe ich nämlich noch nicht getan.
Kann ja sein, dass es vielleicht nicht funktioniert oder so bei einem Zuschauer.
Ach so.
Hier kann ich mir das nicht vorstellen.
Allerdings ist es immer besser, erst alles zu testen.
Das ist echt nur innen. Ich habe das auch schon oft außen drauf gelegt.
Das ist gut zu wissen.
... zusammenbaut, sonst muss man alles wieder zerlegen.
Was ist das, Druckluft oder sowas?
Sind...
Wo wir gerade bei bei Leitend sind, da muss ich euch auch mal eine Big Brain Aktion von mir zeigen.
Package, nicht Package.
Die Raspberry Pis, die kommen in so einem Gehäuse hier.
Zero, zero.
Ja, schön, dass man das nicht sieht.
Die Raspberry Pis kommen in so einem Metallgehäuse, die Zeros.
Ich muss euch das Gehäuse zeigen, dass ihr wisst, was ich verkackt habe.
Zero.
Warum zeigen die das hier?
Hier, da.
Die kommen in so einem Gehäuse.
So, und da passen die richtig gut rein.
Und ich dachte mir, ich bin richtig Big Brain.
Ich mache es einfach so, ich lege den Raspberry Pi wieder ins Gehäuse rein.
Und ihr könnt euch vorstellen, was passiert, wenn wir den hier mit der Unterseite in das Gehäuse reinlegt.
Von unten sieht so ein Raspberry Pi Zero nämlich so aus.
Von unten sieht ein Raspberry Pi Zero nämlich so aus.
Und man sieht da jede Menge schöne Kontakte.
Und wenn man die auf einen Metallboden legt,
zumal ich glaube auch noch GPIOs reingelötet hatte von der anderen Seite.
Das heißt, die Unterseite von den GPIOs, man hat hier noch rausgeguckt.
So, und wenn man das dann auf so einen Metallboden vom Gehäuse legt,
dann war er einfach kaputt.
Hat kurz geraucht und dann war aus.
Das war keine allzu clevere Idee.
Ich habe mir gedacht, oh das sieht aber schön klein und kompakt aus,
wenn ich das einfach in dem Gehäuse, in dieser, naja.
Ja, man lernt nie aus.
Da hat Smonker smoked.
Und dann machen wir mal eben den schnellen Funktionstest.
Und mir ist aufgefallen, wie sauber der Kram ist.
Das ist man sonst nicht gewöhnt, so eigentlich.
Ich hätte jetzt gedacht, dass der Kühler voll sitzt mit Staub und so weiter.
Guck, der hat auch gebrauchte Sachen von eBay gekauft.
Weil, ich würde gerade sagen, ansonsten wird es echt schwierig mit 257 Euro.
Weil Warzone läuft eh schon ultra beschissen.
Mein Rechner ist nicht schlecht.
Und das läuft beschissen.
Und du kannst selbst auf 130, 90 läuft es wahrscheinlich beschissen.
Weil Warzone kacke programmiert das.
So richtig räudig.
Man merkt dem an, dass es eigentlich im Kern ein Game ist,
was auf kleineren Multiplayer-Maps läuft.
Das siehst du bei Warzone teilweise.
Wenn du ranzoomst und der, also wenn du auf diesem,
wenn du am Flughafen auf dem Turm bist und zooms an den Flughafen ran,
dann wird der Flughafen teilweise nur halb geladen und sowas.
Und das sieht dann quasi aus wie ein N64-Game.
Er war sogar so freundlich und hat diese Dinger wieder auf der, ja wie heißt die?
Vielleicht ist es besser geworden,
aber ich kann es mir nicht vorstellen.
Also es ist schon bestimmt drei Monate her,
wo ich letztes Mal Warzone gespielt habe, aber gut war es nicht.
Gut lief das nicht.
Nee, geile Ahnung.
Auf jeden Fall ist ja das Ding oben dazwischen ist das Mainboard
und unten drunter ist eben so eine Platte,
damit man entweder die alten AM3-Kühler verwenden kann,
die sich hier dran befestigen lassen.
Also das läuft zum größten Teil tatsächlich gar nicht schlecht.
Bis halt auf diese Sachen, wie das Sachen nicht,
also dass zum Beispiel die Geometrie vom Flughafen nicht geladen wird
und dass du Sachen einploppen hast und sowas an sich,
wenn du einfach nur dastehst und guckst in der Gegend rum,
dann läuft es gut.
Dass man diese Kühler hier befestigen kann
und auch die hat er zurückgerüstet quasi.
Das ist ein sehr feiner Zug von ihm.
Und hier habe ich gesehen, da haben wir noch einen BIOS-Switch.
Und ich habe den Eindruck, die faken die FPS in Warzone.
Also nicht, dass die FPS richtig gefaked sind,
aber ich habe das Gefühl, die berechnen Sachen intern
mit deutlich niedrigeren Raten, als es die FPS weiß machen wollen.
So nach dem Motto, du hast 250 FPS,
aber wenn du gewisse Aktionen durchführst,
über was drüber springen und sonst was,
dann fühlt sich das an, als wird es mit 10 FPS,
als wird es nur zehnmal in der Sekunde irgendwie neu berechnet,
weil das teilweise übelst haklich einem vorkommt.
Gerade durch Fenster springen und sowas.
Obwohl du 250 FPS hast.
Ist ein bisschen wie damals in Battlefield 3,
wo du fünfmal versuchen musstest, über eine Mauer zu springen.
Gleich mal nachschauen.
Wichtig ist, dass das Ding erstmal einschaltet.
Schnappen wir uns mal schnell einen Schraubenzieher.
Jump auf Frontpanel.
Ah, war doch richtig. Ja, okay.
Oh, es leuchtet sogar. Cool.
Es leuchtet blau, Leute. Was ist es?
Das blaue Licht.
Schauen, ob er auch den Arbeitsspeicher vernünftig erkannt hat.
16 GB, alles klar.
Dann würde ich sagen, verfrachten wir das Ganze mal in das Gehäuse.
Bestes Klebeband, was er da hinten hat.
Habt ihr es gesehen?
16 GB, alles klar.
Dann...
Bestes Klebeband.
Ich weiß nicht, ob man es richtig erkennt.
Ich würde sagen, verfrachten wir das Ganze mal in das Gehäuse
und testen wir mal ein bisschen was.
Aber wie ich das vermisst habe.
Wie lange habe ich kein PC mehr zusammengebaut?
Eine Woche?
Eine Woche? Verdammt.
Da wird es aber...
Da wird man aber langsam schon hübelig,
wenn man eine Woche lang kein PC mehr zusammengebaut hat.
Ich habe ein Gaming-Bild zusammengebaut.
Das habe ich, glaube ich, schon länger nicht mehr gemacht.
Da ist langsam Entzugserscheinungen.
Die Bände am Arm, da darf ich jetzt nichts zu sagen.
Das hatte ich auch mal eine Zeit lang.
Also es sind irgendwelche Festivalbände oder so.
Also mal heißt vor...
Irgendwann fragt mich nicht, 2004 oder so.
Das ist schon ein bisschen näher.
Wacken, Rock am Ring, ein paar Sachen.
Und das, obwohl ich Menschenansammlungen nicht mag.
So, gucke mal, ich ist fertig.
Ja, nicht ganz. Mir ist aufgefallen, dass dieses Teil hier fehlt.
Ach, so eine Mainboard-Blende, wer braucht denn sowas?
Das ist komplett overrated.
Vielleicht hat es der Vorbesitzer, vielleicht habe ich das verbummelt,
aber ich habe mit dem Gehäuse dann wohl noch gar nichts gemacht,
weil da noch Staub drin war.
Eine ganze Menge sogar.
Und deswegen habe ich das gerade mal eben rausgeräumt.
Und dann schauen wir mal, ob es immer noch funktioniert.
Das stimmt.
Chat sagt, Festivals sind aber normal immer sehr gechillt, finde ich.
Muss ich auch sagen, das ging wirklich...
Ich fände es nur immer lustig,
dass die überall irgendwelche Insider-Wörter hatten.
Bei Rock am Ring war es Helga und sowas.
Wo ich mir gesagt habe, hä?
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob das immer noch angesagt ist,
dass die irgendwas mit Helga erzählen.
Gibt es Rock am Ring überhaupt noch?
Gibt es das noch?
Okay, gibt es anscheinend.
Das haben die doch vor ein paar Jahren abgesagt.
Das haben die mal eingestellt.
Aber es gibt es anscheinend wieder.
Ja, also was es mit Helga auf sich hat, keine Ahnung.
Da gibt es ja zig Videos und Sachen dazu,
die einem das angeblich erklären wollen,
aber niemand weiß es.
Wahrscheinlich ist es genau so, wie ich damals
mit dem Friseur dummes Zeug gelabert habe
und wir haben dann immer wieder die gleichen Wörter verwendet.
So wird es da auch sein.
Irgendwelche Leute haben damit angefangen
und die anderen haben es nachgelabert.
Da war der Reset-Knopf, den ich da drauf gesteckt habe.
Reset-Reset-Knopf.
Aber RGB, so muss das sein.
So, ihr beide leuchtet Lichterloh und du da hinten, ah.
Hauptsache grüne RGBs.
Und die RGB-Leiste muss hin.
Wo ist die RGB-Leiste?
Ach, nur grün.
Oh, es ist doch kein RGB.
Es ist dann kein RGB.
Es ist nur G oder was?
Von RGB ist G übrig geblieben.
G-LED.
Wenn ich nur noch eine Nvidia-Grafik hatte drin sein, dann ist das ein grünes Thema.
Ich war mal so frei und habe vorhin schon mal eben Windows installiert,
während ich noch eben was anderes gemacht habe.
Der Chat, der Chat will es wieder wissen.
Aber wie viel G?
Etwa 5G.
Painstrap.
Oder ist es sogar nur 3G?
4G.
6G.
Und bei 6G ist ja WLAN dann schon wieder.
Boomerwitze.
Na komm, also, ich gebe zu, die sind nicht gut.
Aber Boomerwitze sind es nicht.
Da ist es drin verbaut.
Wohlan.
Und so wird aus...
Das sieht ja sogar richtig ordentlich aus.
Ohohohohohohohohohohohui.
Die 6 Euro RGB-Leiste.
Na ja.
Sieht ehrlich gesagt total beschissen aus.
So mit dem grünen Lüfter, neben der LED-Leiste.
Also sieht irgendwie nicht gut aus.
Ich mein, so ist okay, so ist okay.
So ein bisschen, so ein bisschen, so ein bisschen gleich.
Okay, ist in Ordnung.
Aber am Anfang sah wirklich kacke aus.
Ich bin diesmal den Weg gegangen und habe die Leisten nochmal extra mit 3M-Kleber.
Bestes Klebeband, Leute.
Bestes Klebeband, müsst ihr euch holen, wenn ihr das habt.
Nach einem Jahr oder sowas, diese Leisten auch mal runterhängen können.
Und das möchte ich nicht.
Man sieht hier, da habe ich da an der Ecke noch so ein bisschen verstärkt.
Ah, yes.
Ich will eben nicht, dass es runterfällt.
So.
Und es war bei diesem Gehäuse ja leider so, dass dieses Stück hier gefehlt hat.
Entweder habe ich es verschlammt oder es war der Vorbesitzer.
Ich habe da nicht ganz drauf geachtet.
Aber wer es nicht kennt, hier habe ich ein fast ähnliches Gehäuse.
Das ist einfach nur so eine Klappe, die kannst du abnehmen.
Da kannst du eine Grafikkarte oder eine Soundcard oder so einbauen.
Dann machst du das Ding wieder zu und dann ist das auch zu.
Ja, Moment.
Aber da kann man doch nichts reinstecken, wenn es zu ist.
Ich bin da jetzt aber hingegangen und habe, wie man schon sieht, dort ein wenig Pappe genommen.
Und zwar hier von der...
Manchmal muss man erfinderisch sein.
Verpackung, kann man so machen.
Genauso ähnlich geht es der PCI-Blender.
Einfach mal das Handbuch dazwischen gesteckt.
Passende, aber ich habe mir gedacht, ja, warum nicht?
Dieses Stück Pappe habe ich vorher ausgeschnitten, um irgendwas nachzuschauen.
Keine Ahnung.
Kannst du auch machen, dann fällt es zumindest nicht auf.
Kannst du festkleben mit dem Stück.
Finde ich gar nicht so schlecht.
Sieht auf jeden Fall schon mal besser aus, wenn man diese entsprechenden Dinger nicht hat.
Finde ich wohl ganz cool.
So, und jetzt mache ich noch ein paar Benchmarks.
Zeige es euch dann gleich und dann sind wir eigentlich schon fertig.
An sich gab es hier keine Probleme beim Zusammenbauen oder bei der Kompatibilität.
Das lief alles von Anfang an.
Schön zu sehen bei diesem Gehäuse.
Du kannst hier ein DVD-Laufwerk einbauen.
Das sieht man heutzutage nicht mehr überall.
Zumindest bei einer solchen Gehäuseart, sage ich jetzt mal.
DVD in 2020.
Aber das ist eine echt schlaue Idee, finde ich.
Ich glaube, das lasse ich einfach so.
Big Brain Idee.
Wenn jemand fragt, ja, das...
Ich würde einfach sagen, das war so.
Was ist das da unten für ein Benchmark?
Das Witcher 3 oder so?
Nee, was ist das?
Was ist das da unten für einer?
Valley Bench...
Ah!
Da kenne ich die neuen Versionen gar nicht.
Ja, Valley Benchmark ist das.
Warthorn sieht immer so aus, als mit Ruckeln, hä?
Warthorn wird immer so aus, als mit Ruckeln, hä?
Also Warthorn war immer so, als mit Ruckeln, hä?
Also Warthorn mit 71 FPS fühlt sich an wie 30.
Hast du das Spiel noch?
Nee.
Ich habe es wieder deinstalliert.
Hat so viel Festplattenplatz weggenommen.
Nee, ich habe es doch schon drei Monate nicht mehr gespielt.
Guck mal, wie das ruckelt.
Das ist so ein bisschen...
Und das soll 106 FPS sein.
Gut, das könnte rein vom Aufnehmen sein, ja.
Okay, jetzt kommt eine Runde Fortnite.
Oder ist das Fortnite wahrscheinlich?
Guck mal, das sieht viel flüssiger aus.
Okay, nee, jetzt hat es gemikro ruckelt.
Null.
Sag mal, der Fortnite-Hype, der ist nicht mehr so hype, ne?
Ich meine, es gucken immer noch viele Leute.
Keine Frage, das ist immer noch mit das beliebteste Spiel auf Twitch.
Aber so dieser Ultrahype, dass die Kinder vorm Bus Loser Dance machen,
ist schon wieder, ist schon wieder, ist schon vorbei, ne?
Guck mal, nur 57K.
Also wie gesagt, ich hatte mal am Südbahnhof Kinners,
die auf die, also nicht nur einmal, die sind auf die,
die sind vor die S-Bahn, vor die Straßenbahn gesprungen.
Also als die gehalten hat an der Haltestelle,
sind die vor die S-Bahn gesprungen und haben ein Loser Dance gemacht.
So mit diesem Beine hin und her gewackele und diesem L vorm Kopf.
Da habe ich mir auch gedacht, hoffentlich wäre die Bahn gleich los, ey.
Na gut, Minecraft läuft ja überall.
Wobei, bis es Ja war.
Okay, ich nehme das zurück, das läuft auch nicht überall.
So, ich nehme einen Schluck aus Chiaras vergessener Flasche hier.
Dann kann es auch kein Product Placement geben, was ich hier trinke.
Also von daher.
Aber die Vorteil-Performance ist darauf zurückzuführen,
dass der Arbeitsspeicher womöglich nicht im Dual-Channel,
1000 FPS, blablabla.
Ich habe es nicht mehr ganz im Hinterkopf gehabt,
aber hier können wir vertrauen.
15 Euro manchmal, aber die Zeit.
Ja, ich meine, die Sachen auf eBay kaufen für so ein ultra-low-end-budget-Ding
ist gar nicht mal so schlecht.
Die Frage ist, ob hier Warsound überhaupt draufpasst.
Ich meine, Windows, brauchst du mal so, was braucht man da aktuell,
wenn du da alles drauf hast, 30, 40G.
Da wird es für Fortnite, also Fortnite und Warsound
sind da schon mal nicht drauf.
Das wird eng, das wird auf jeden Fall sehr eng,
da Warsound draufzukriegen.
Cold War soll wohl bei Release über...
Die haben komplett den Arsch offen.
Was machen die denn?
Was musst du machen, dass du so ein Game auf 200GB kriegst?
Unkomprimierte Videos und Audios.
Was machst du denn da?
Guck mal den Link, Max.
Okay, Moment.
Ich kann den Link nicht öffnen.
Jetzt.
Ah doch, guck mal.
250G-Platte reicht gerade so aus.
Da ist aber auch Singleplayer und alles installiert, oder?
Wobei, kann man das überhaupt getrennt installieren?
Kann man Singleplayer, Multiplayer und Warsound getrennt installieren?
Na ja, da hat er noch 5G für Windows frei, muss doch reichen.
Zweifelsfall Windows XP draufmachen.
Aber dann läuft Warsound wieder nicht.
Doch stimmt, man hat bloß 237.
Je nachdem, ob es mit 1000 oder 1024 rechnest.
Wenn es mit 1024 rechnest, hast du ein bisschen weniger.
Im Prinzip hast du ja immer gleich viel, aber es ist halt Rechensache.
Ist nur kleiner, wenn du das Hauptspiel nicht gekauft hast.
Okay, also macht es sogar Sinn, wenn du das Hauptspiel nicht gekauft hast.
Okay, also macht sogar Sinn, sich das Hauptspiel nicht zu kaufen.
Macht es auch so Sinn, weil das Hauptspiel sackt.
Die Kampagne ist na ja, und der Multiplayer ist komplett zu vergessen.
Der Multiplayer von Modern Warfare ist wirklich Payne's Champ hoch 10.
Weiß nicht, was wir noch gucken sollen.
Best Mom, wir gucken eine Runde Battlefield 4.
Wir gucken eine Runde Battlefield.
Den muss ich nicht so laut machen, weil der erzählt eh immer das Gleiche.
Okay, ich weiß, was passiert.
Ich predicte, ich predicte jetzt mal, der fliegt mit dem LRV über die Mappen.
Der fliegt mit dem LRV über die Mappen.
Ich predicte jetzt mal, der fliegt mit dem LRV über die Mappen.
Ich gucke jetzt gleich durch die Luft, ich sage es euch.
Was zum Teufel passiert?
Der bounce jetzt und fliegt.
Ich wusste es.
Ich weiß, es kann mir keiner erzählen, Battlefield wäre eine Simulation.
Es gibt ja Leute, die behaupten das.
Aber ich finde es geil, dass sowas funktioniert.
Mir ist es viel lieber, du kannst so abgedrehten Scheiß machen.
Wie in Battlefield 5, wo du nicht mehr richtig über Felsen klettern kannst.
Ich finde, das hat irgendwie was.
Mir ist es viel lieber, du kannst so abgedrehten Scheiß machen.
Alter, die spawnen auch noch da oben wieder rein.
Sind die komplett Pepega im Kopf?
Ja und keiner versucht auch noch mal drauf zu schießen.
Die ganze Mannschaft, oder mindestens 20 Mitglieder, sind ausgedreht.
Nächstes Mal ist es Naddud und das hier war ein AEK-Spraydown.
Wir reden über das Spotten in Battlefield 4 und wie kaputt es ist.
Das ist pure Glück.
Ja, das Spotting, in Bad Company 2 hast du auch so komisches Spotting.
Was zahlst du eigentlich für deinen Server an Stromrechnung?
Kannst du dir ausrechnen?
Idle, so ungefähr 12 Watt.
Kannst du mal ausrechnen?
12 Watt, Idle, 24,7.
Ich weiß aber nicht, was ich für Strompreis bezahle.
Standard, keine Ahnung, was sind so Standard?
27 Cent, ich habe keine Ahnung.
0,27, ja nicht 27.
Irgendwie sowas.
Rechnen wir doch mal aus.
Strompreis, Strompreisrechner oder sowas.
Watt.
Gibt es bestimmt sowas.
Stromverbrauch Punkt Info.
Klingt extrem vertrauenserwecken.
12,13.
Geben Sie die Stunden ein, 24.
Strompreis kostet mich im Jahr.
Hä?
Das ergibt keinen Sinn.
Ach, das ist am Tag.
Ach so.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, okay, das ist am Tag.
So, das heißt mal 365.
Nee.
Wie viele Tage hat das Jahr?
365, 356.
Schnelle Infopunkte.
Wie?
Das steht doch nicht mal da.
Was?
Ein normales Jahr, 260 Tage?
Moment, wo bin ich hier gelandet?
365 Tage.
Okay.
Wie, das kannste nicht ausrechnen?
Hallo?
Alter, was ist denn das?
Warum kann das Google nicht ausrechnen?
Vielleicht muss man einen Punkt dazwischen machen.
Okay, 31 Euro bezahle ich im Jahr.
Nee.
31 Euro bezahle ich im Jahr.
Das kann ich verkraften.
So, guck mal weiter, Battlefield.
Also, 31 Euro ist okay.
Bam.
Oh, das sind die besten.
Oh, oh, oh, der ist gut.
Das ist ein exquisite Clip.
Ich dachte eigentlich nur, es ist ein normaler Clip.
Und die sind schon selten.
Die Clips sind schon selten, wo die Leute aus dem Chat springen
und wieder in den Chat reinkommen.
Aber er ist auf dem Chat gesp...
Moment, ist das ein doppelter Chat?
Nee, ne?
Der ist da schon Pilot vorher.
Das ist huge.
Poggers Clip.
Ah, Comets, wieder am Start.
Ah, das fliegt.
Okay, okay.
Der schießt jetzt das Ding...
Okay, was?
What?
Okay, das ist was, das geht bloß in Battlefield-Physics.
Das geht nur in Battlefield-Physics.
Das geht in keinem anderen Game.
Und jetzt schießt er noch den Heli ab.
Okay, so was geht echt nur in Battlefield.
Moment, nochmal.
Die Battlefield-Physics ist aber das Beste.
Oh, da wirst du ja motion sick.
Und wieder rein.
Wobei man ja sagen muss...
Die Chats fallen unrealistisch langsam.
Aber wir wollen uns ja am halben Punkt
den Realismus hier jetzt nicht auslassen.
Ich mein, das ist ein Spiel,
das uns das alles nicht mehr einfach zu machen hat.
Die Chats fallen unrealistisch langsam.
Aber wir wollen uns ja am halben Punkt
den Realismus hier nicht auslassen.
Ich mein, das ist ein Spiel,
hier nicht auslassen ich meine das ist ein spiel wo die leute aus dem chat aussteigen können rpg rausholen gegnerischen heli rpg
und in den chat einsteigen ist kein ding
das ist diese map mit den drop pots die habe ich glaube ich nur einmal gespielt
oh der war cool
ich meine es könnte natürlich auch sein dass es die anderen spiele nicht zeigen
weil wir nicht die geheimen taktiken sehen sollen
ich meine wer weiß was was gerade die amis special special forces troups da so geile
dinge für geile stunts aus dem heli machen können ja
freedom
erstmal wie in echt aus dem heli springen 360 ein no-scope-snipern und will ein heli einsteigen
warum springen die l.a.v.'s wenn man was muss man machen was muss man machen dass der l.a.v. im
wasser springt das springt ja nicht einfach so muss man den richtigen winkel treffen oder wie
ist das es things und on the console i'm sure they're giving it away very cheaply and for moments
like that in the law it's definitely worth getting the game i'm trying to record some clips like this
total pro get
Alte F4 dabei drücken, Payne's Champ, nicht nur ich kann unlustige Witze machen, das ist
cool erstmal den anderen Pilot überfahren und in den Chat rein. Warum ist der andere Typ überhaupt
ausgestiegen? Zack, nice und jetzt zack wieder rein in den Chat. Moment an den Clip kann ich mich
noch erinnern. Stimmt, das hat ja einen Kommando Modus. Gab es den nicht auf dem Tablet, konnte
man nicht vom Tablet aus Kommando Modus spielen und das haben sie dann wieder rausgepatcht oder
sowas? Oder geht das noch? Oder geht das noch? Übers Web und vom Tablet. Geht das noch? Sie
haben die App nicht mehr geupdatet, aber geht die App noch?
Das Xbox? Ist das Xbox 360 Graphics? Das sieht so schlecht aus. Ne, die Auflösung ist zu hoch
für Xbox. Ne, die Xbox 360 konnte kein, die hat Battlefield, sogar Battlefield 3 war intern
in 980, 840p oder sowas. Ja, du konntest upscalen auf 1080p, aber das hat die interne Auflösung
von dem Game nicht höher gemacht. Willst du die Bilder von Cold War Streamen? Ich weiß
nicht, ich werde sie mir auf jeden Fall mal angucken, aber ich gehe davon aus, dass mich
das nach drei Runden spätestens wenn Skill-based Matchmaking reinkickt wieder so abfacken wird,
dass ich mir es nicht länger geben kann. Wann ist denn die überhaupt? Wann ist denn die Cold
War Beta? 8. Oktober, also sprich ab Donnerstag. Ach ne Moment, das ist PS4. Wo ist PC? Ach
hier ist PC, 17. Oktober. Also Vorbestellen tue ich nicht, aber wisst ihr was ich mache?
Wisst ihr was ich mache? Ich gehe zu irgendeinem Key-Shop und suche mir irgendwelche Beta,
die gibt es bestimmt, gibt es garantiert, irgendwelche Beta Zugänge. Dann spiele ich
schon am 17. Oder am 15. Das kostet, die Beta Zugänge in den Key-Shops kosten meistens
nix. Das kostet genau 2 Euro oder so. Besser als Vorbestellen. Ich wusste gar nicht, dass
man kriechen kann mit einem 2 Bein an der LMG. Geiler Tweet. 250 GSSD ist zu klein. Das
ist doch echter Witz. Das ist doch total, 250G sind die noch komplett bei Sinnen. Alter,
was geht mit dem ab? Was geht mit dem ab? Der wird es ja schlecht bei. Wtf? Mit schlecht
Wtf? Pong aus Clip. Und jetzt killt er den Jet noch. Jawoll. Jetzt freut er sich. Ja,
das geht oft. Die brauchen da ewig lang zum Downloaden. Sag! What? Warum macht er noch
mal Intro? Ich glaube, das hat er aus dem alten Video reingeschnitten jetzt. Zack. Ja,
sag mal, spielen irgendwie ultra viele Russen das Game noch? Wann glaubst du, bekommt man
wieder 3080? Also ich gehe davon aus, dass man Anfang nächsten Jahres dann wieder gut
3080 und 3090 bekommen wird. Irgendwann Mitte Januar oder so. Es war zumindest das letzte
Mal so. Es könnte durchaus sein, dass man sogar noch im Dezember welche bekommt. Je
nachdem, wieviel sie da noch anpacken können. Moment, den Clip kenn ich noch. Den Clip
kenn ich noch. Die schießen doch jetzt den Heli mit dem Baumstamm ab.
Wir gucken gleich mal auf Ebay, was eine 3090 kosten würde. Die wollen ja wahrscheinlich
Jetzt schießen sie den Heli ab. Ich mein, das kann Setup sein, Leute. Es ist möglich,
dass das Setup ist, aber es ist trotzdem cool. Warum fliegt er genau da hin und genau da
runter? Bäm. Nicht schlecht. Wie geht denn das überhaupt?
Die Spiegelungen sind schon ein bisschen falsch hier auf dem Geländer.
Ne, das Video hab ich nicht gesehen, aber ich hab's gelesen, dass die irgendwie Probleme
mit Stromversorgung haben. What? Hat er sich gerade in den Turm geklitscht
über die stationäre MG? Oh, das ist Big Brain Play. Way too smart hier. Das ist richtig
Big Brain, aber die Gegner checken halt auch mal wieder gar nichts. Das ist richtig gut.
Ja, mag sein, dass das altbekannter Trick ist, aber der Clip ist trotzdem nice. Also
ich wusste das noch nicht. Warum stehen die alle wie angewurzelt da?
Ich bin Begas. Also ich kannte das noch nicht, dass das geht mit der MG. Sollte ich mal mit
der Battlefield 4 spielen, probiere ich es aus. Und Bäm. Jetzt. Ne. Jetzt durch. Jetzt
geht's gleich was essen, wenn wir nur ein paar Sachen angeguckt haben. Okay, das ist jetzt
aber mal echt sehr auf gut Glück, ey. Oh, oh, oh, Bäm. Das war nun wirklich. Also,
das war schon ein bisschen predicted, aber zu 90 Prozent. Fliegt er jetzt? Der fliegt
jetzt mit dem Jet da drüber und sprengt in die Luft. Das ist wirklich Spock. Richtig,
was? Was zum? Wie hat er den überhaupt gesehen? Ach, da ist einer. Tatsächlich. Was macht
der Gegner da? Warum ist der da überhaupt? Ja, mir kommen die Clips auch bekannt vor,
aber das ist ja quasi ein Best-of-Best-of. Console-Grafics. All die PP-Ger-Gegner.
Den Clip haben wir auch schon gesehen. Jetzt laufen sie alle schön hintereinander. Bäm.
Ha, ha, ha. Der guckt doch gar nicht mehr
hin. Kommt mal, der guckt gar nicht hin. Und auf einmal Bäm. Ha, ha, ha. Gleich gibt's
kleine Boote, ey. Ist ja geil, dass das funktioniert. Alter. Sehr nice. Sehr nice. Irgendwie erinnere
mich das ein bisschen daran. Warte mal. Oh, oh mein Gott. Oh, oh mein fucking Gott. Oh,
oh mein Gott. Yani ich kann keinen oui nicht
war das letzte preis war das letzte preis für 30 90 rtx
suche ach suche
normalerweise kostet 1300 euro sind die noch sind oder 1000 was was kostet normalerweise 1300 1400
sind die noch bei sinnen angebote ich meine das sind einfach mal 900 euro mehr oder 1600 ok
das sind einfach mal 600 euro mehr ich hoffe das kauft sich ja ich hoffe auch das kauft sich
keiner die sind noch nicht die sind doch nicht mal sind doch immer ganz bei trost an was 1600
hat es echt gekostet ich habe doch hier beim nvidia shop geguckt
die sind doch echt das ist doch voll für ein arsch aber das ist jedes mal so das ist ja nichts
neues also die meisten übertreiben es aber nicht so es gibt so ein paar kack shops das sieht man
auch hier die hier welche anbieten und ja pc king zum beispiel also der shop mit der besten also
wer mit wer hier nicht bestellt der weit der weiß auch nicht was er verpasst 2,1 sterne klingt
klingt wirklich was skalper was ist denn ein skalper ja gut ja aber ich mein 2300 euro ist
schon echt lächerlich wenn es das sind einfach 700 euro mehr als normal da vom restlichen
graben ist ja auch nichts mehr lieferbar und das letzte mal als wir geguckt haben stand noch
deutlich mehr auf lieferbar von denen das heißt die sind den graben sogar losgeworden zu dem preis
aber ich sehe das sehe ich nicht ein ich meine klar es steht allen samt frei die sache dafür
anzubieten also das ist erlaubt es ist nicht so als wäre das verboten oder so sei denn es gibt
da irgendwas von nvidia aber glaube ich eher nicht sind ich verboten also sprich wenn ich das dafür
anbieten den man sagt ich kaufe mir das man das ist das ist letztendlich ok da kann es an sich
nichts gegen sagen aber ich kaufe es mir nicht dafür wenn 500 euro mehr ist auch schon heftig
sondern was ist wenn man auf ebay sucht
das geht doch noch am moment das geht ja noch fünf tage das ist
eine aktion die fünf tage geht ok diese am ende auch bei 2000 euro oder so
nee nee nee nee um hat er hier in den zettel dran hängen
alles klar jetzt wittern sie alle irgendwie hier die schnellen stonks wittern sie alle die
ganzen verkäufer also ich meine für den preis kommt man auch wenigstens ein ordentliches
produktfoto machen oder ist klar ist klar ich meine das kann sein das kann sein aber ich
glaube es ihm nicht ich glaube ihm eher dass er das absichtlich gekauft haben es wieder
zu verkaufen auf der anderen seite hätte sie eingepackt gelassen vielleicht vielleicht
stimmt doch vielleicht stimmt doch ich meine wenn ich sehr einfach gekauft hätte um sie
wieder zu verkaufen dann hätte ich sie dann hätte ich sie auf jeden fall nicht ausgepackt
jetzt wollte es aber wissen oder kein fake nidl sind fünf monat dankeschön
also jetzt jetzt sind sie ein bisschen größer wahnsinnig geworden oder
jetzt sind sie ein bisschen größer ich dachte am anfang erst er hat zwei grafikkarten
das ist so die das ist so die standard ausrede weil sie nicht in mein gehäuse passt das
hat diese aussage macht das ist so die standard ausrede mittlerweile ist klar deswegen verkaufen
will ich die dann auch verkaufen für 3000 euro einfach mal 1500 euro grafikkarte kaufen
und kein neues dann würde ich mein neues gehäuse holen passt das eigentlich passt
das eigentlich bei mir rein wird das eigentlich hier reinpassen ja bestimmt oder das gehäuse
ist schon fett äh länge länge specs specs äh wo stehts äh ich bin dazu blöd für
das ist das ist wenn du die festplatten auf der gleichen höhe drin hast aber ohne festplatten
auf der gleichen höhe ja passt easy passt das das passt easy rein ich weiß nicht was
die braucht aber aber unter 400 würde ich sagen wie lang ist die steht das da ja passt
easy rein ich habe da eh keine festplatten eingebaut auf der höhe das passt also das
ist hier unten auf der höhe vom pci express slot zeigt mal bilder vom gehäuse ja das
ist so hier hier so auf der höhe dann du hast die hier vorne hast kannst du auch noch
platten du kannst hier oben macht halt deine ssd und gedöns rein und hier unten das passt
da ist musste keine fest ich meine es sei denn jemand möchte irgendwie acht festplatten
oder so noch in seinem gehäuse machen dann ist ok ja aber ich warte erst mal bis es wieder
was gibt zu normalen preisen weil das hier ist ja nur wirklich der witz schlechthin
ich hatte mal eine inno 3d karte die hatte wirklich mit abstand den besten namen aller
zeiten zwar inno 3d ich bin mir nicht sicher welches war die 900 ich glaube die 980 ja
ich glaube da war sogar noch irgendwo herkules mit drinne im namen inno 3d ein schild x4
airbus ultra das ist so hier herkules genau und wirklich keiner die noch herkules im namen
drinne gehabt ja inno 3d ein schild gtx 89 herkules x4 airbus ultra der namen war echt
mit abstand der der geilste grafik namen aller zeiten das war 2014 so lange ist das schon
her wirklich ja den fällt schon den fällt schon noch etwas aber jetzt jetzt haben es
ein bisschen kürzer gemacht jetzt heißt das ding noch ich schild x x3 ok aber rgb ich
stelle nicht vor ich vorbestellen wird da nicht ich werde das definitiv im leben nicht
vorbestellen so was wir uns angucken können die plot in firestick haben wir hier day in
the life of a data center mal gucken mal gucken ob ich da ein bisschen was zu erzählen kann
als jeder server einbauen oder sowas wie gesagt ich habe früher mal beim provider gearbeitet
habe ich das auch selbst öfters machen müssen die haben schon mal den großen vorteil die
jungs hier die sind zu zweit wir mussten das teilweise alleine machen und wer mal quasi
auf auf über kopfhöhe server ins reg eingebaut hat weiß wie toll das ist das stimmt es
macht der chat ist hier ist wirklich
also ich muss mir den server öfters auf den kopf legen bei sowas weil wir die hände
teilweise gebraucht also man hat den server dann so halb ins reg rein gebastelt und hat
sich den rest dann so auf den kopf gelegt so versucht das war ganz abenteuerlich aber
die machen es richtig weil ich habe schon mitgekriegt wie das ist wenn einem so ein
wenn einem so ein ding auf den fußzähl fällt es war ein alter in 6 oder so ja so ein ding
also ich habe ich habe schon mitgekriegt wie das ist wenn jemand also mir ist es nicht
auf den fuß gefallen aber wenn jemand so ein ding hier auf den fuß fällt
ich glaube die mussten den zee sogar wieder nähen danach wahrscheinlich war der ab oder
so also das war echt nicht nicht nicht schön also seht ihr mal auch so computer zeug kann
gefährlich sein die sind aber richtig also die machen es richtig die haben handschuhe
die haben sicherheitsschuhe diese wagen ich glaube in jedem rz gibt es diese wagen wisst ihr
was an diesen wagen mega beschissen ist die haben nur hinten sachen zum lenken man kann
diese wagen nicht richtig lenken ich weiß gar nicht wer sich das ausgedacht hat dass man das
hinten warum baut man den scheiß so das ist das ist mega kacke ich weiß nicht ob was in dem
video noch sieht man kann die dinger kaum richtig lenken man muss die dinger ziehen ja aber manchmal
gerade wenn du in zwischen die reine fährst willst du eigentlich sehen wo du hin fährst
sind das britten keine ahnung kann schon sein
ja oder der gute data center sound hier
hier oben haben sie inne wahrscheinlich nicht ganz 5,60 aliexpress kamera das habe ich mich
nie getraut ich habe mich nie getraut die türne auszuhängen also bei uns im rz gab es nur diese
großen fetten schützer also diese diese schwarz roten schützer die man sich so was
gemacht hat aber nach 20 30 minuten war das so unangenehm dass du die dinger einfach nur
ausgezogen hast und dann hast du halt die lautstärke gegeben die gucken nicht so glücklich also was man
jetzt macht also die machen es richtig die machen es richtig was man jetzt machen muss ist damit
man diese diese leisten überhaupt einsetzen kann da braucht man diese klipse ich weiß nicht wie
die dinger heißen so die die klammern also die leisten halten ja nicht einfach so im rack man
muss man muss hier so so klipse dazwischen machen wo man dann später das heißt doch die leisten
halten die leisten kann man einhängen aber die sind nicht wirklich belastet du kannst die selber
nicht richtig festschrauben du musst da vorne klipse rein machen und in die klipse kannst du
dann die schrauben machen ich glaube das sieht man gleich ich weiß aber nicht wie diese käfig
muttern heißt das der chat ist wieder mal voll und on point hier genau diese nee was auch immer das
ist da hinten dran jeder braucht man dafür hat wahrscheinlich noch nie jemand gesehen der nicht
in meinem audio oder z betrieb zusammengebaut hat weil mir fällt nichts ein wofür man diesen
kram sonst braucht ja und das hat auch den vorteil wenn man dann was rein dann drückt sich das noch
weiter auseinander also das ist genauso sind die aus die klips man so rein die kann man so
zusammendrücken und dann drücken die sich wieder ein bisschen auseinander wenn die schraube durch
macht also es sieht nicht so aus aber das ist wirklich bomben fest das zeug das ist wirklich
bomben fest da ist nichts mit einfach mal rausziehen oder so also ja das ist wirklich richtig fest
das muss gestellt sein das rz ist zu aufgeräumt also es soll dienstleister geben die das tatsächlich
hinkriegen also vom hören sagen habe ich bei uns sah das natürlich auch nie so ordentlich aus
das sind auch die fetten leisten die die haltendlich was aus ja man kann das vorn
zurückschieben also die guten die ordentlichen leisten da muss man nicht das rack verschieben
sondern kann die leiste kleiner und größer machen bis zu einem gewissen zeit bis zu einem
gewissen punkt aber manche server hersteller denken sich halt wer braucht verstellbare leisten
verstellt auch eure rex die guten die guten vera kraftform elektro schraubendreher
sah zumindest so aus
da macht es klick
die haben ein ziemlich oi 3 hat akzent das könnten die könnten wirklich aus england sein
das sind aber wirklich ordentliche schienen also das sind richtig hier kugel kugel gelagerte
feste stabile schienen das ist schon bisschen was besseres die ollen ibm ein hee kisten die hat
man auch auf so schienen geschoben die also das waren wirklich bloß schienen also das waren nicht
so sachen zum einhängen das war einfach nur schienen wo man die server drauf gefahren hat
bessere schienen als die deutsche waren ja die so aus
die helfen sich sogar die server heben das ist ja immer richtig big brain das muss gestellt sein
wisst ihr was richtig kacke ist wenn ihr die schienen raus macht man muss dann an der seite
oder hier jemand je nachdem wie das ist kann man klipsen und dann gehen die schienen wieder
rein aber wenn ihr den server da drauf hängen haben die schienen hängen oder man bei so einem
low budget provider arbeitet dass man andere schienen als die herstellerschiene für den
server verwendet und da nicht mehr richtig die klipse rein machen kann dann hast du gelitten
dann hast du so eine so eine keine ahnung 40 kilo schwere kiste über deinem kopf hängen
kriegst du immer reingefahren also wir haben manchmal schienen verwendet von anderen server
und die nicht vom hersteller waren weil das war halt so ein bisschen ich will nicht sagen dass es
ein ultra low budget provider war aber das war halt noch das war so 2007 oder so und da war die da
war die welt noch nicht so so polished was das angeht da hat man einfach da hat man einfach
gemacht irgendwie dass es funktioniert hat da wurde mehr hacker mann gemacht als als
ITIL prozesse befolgt bei ITIL ist monka shakes bei mir noch was haben die da für komische
stecker war der mann habe ich mich da gerade verguckt ach nee sind ganz normale aber wo wir
wieder beim thema sind was ich euch immer sage vga im rz vga ich meine die server fangen jetzt
mittlerweile an dass die auch hdmi haben aber teilweise sogar display port aber vga du wirst
keine kiste ohne vga finden du hast nächste woche ITIL schulung oje
vielleicht kommt da noch was rein das ist übrigens auch so eine glaubensfrage ob switcher oben oder
unten ich mag persönlich auch switcher oben am liebsten ich glaube die meisten machen auch
switcher und switcher oben aber es ist so ein bisschen glaubensfrage ob switcher oben oder unten
oder ob netzwerkzeug oben oder unten also ich mag es allein schon weil ich nicht so viel bücken
muss und und es ist auch so da muss ich euch noch was erzählen von unserem rz nicht dass ich jetzt
zu sehr ausholen muss aber die haben ihre also rz reg switcher eingebaut server eingebaut und
irgendwie hat das hat das monitoring system immer gemeckert dass die netzwerk komponenten
so warm geworden sind bis sie dann irgendwann auf die idee gekommen sind sich das ganze mal vor
ort anzugucken also mit ein paar leuten die wissen was sie machen und dann sind sie drauf
gekommen fack wir haben die switcher falsch rum eingebaut und ja so genau und danach haben sie
dann gesagt ok was machen wir jetzt switcher umbauen oder nicht und wisst ihr was sie gemacht haben
was meint ihr was sie gemacht haben switcher richtig rum einbauen oder lüfter tauschen
neu kaufen lüfter umdrehen genau sofern das ging es kann aber auch sein dass ich euch
misst erzähle und die lüfter waren falsch rum und sie haben dann das deswegen falsch rum eingebaut
ich weiß nicht mal genau zumindest haben sie mal die lüfter getauscht stimmt hosti pro im
prinzip hätte man einfach die monitoring werte hoch stellen können dass es erst ab
einer größeren temperatur alarme gibt mangos werden drei monate dankeschön für den sub
big brain subscription wobei ich glaube das sind doch keine wehrer dinger sind andere könnte aber
ist schwer zu erkennen oder doch oder
was die die schneiden wirklich kabel und machen das selbst ok leute ich gebe euch recht das muss
fakes ein das habe ich noch nie erlebt dass sie immer zeit wirklich kabel schneiden und
neue stecker uns das glaube ich da bin ich ja mal gespannt jetzt dass man unterschiedliche
länge je nach einbauhöhe verwendet ich meine big brain und und ordentlicher sieht es aus aber
das macht keiner hangman das die habe ich auch die habe ich auch das sind meine das sind mit
abstand meine lieblings und wäre leck dicker setz ja aber nicht exakt dass das sind die das
sind die aber ich habe das in einem anderen set dass da habe ich genau das set hatte ich
mal vor einer weile gekauft das wirklich nice weil mit dieser mit diesem mit dieser zyklop
ratsche ist das poggers leider ist das bei den wehrraddingern immer so dass man vieles
doppelt hat dadurch zum beispiel ich habe so ein joker schlüssel set noch gekauft also brauche
ich den hier nie und so ein nüsse set habe ich auch beim toolcheck plus dabei werde ich auch
nie brauchen übrigens das hier ist ein schraubenhalter das ist ziemlich cool gemacht also du nimmst
an jeder schraubendreher und dann ich weiß gar nicht mehr überlegt gerade wie rum es geht ja
du klemmst du klemmst quasi die schraube hier durch du machst die schraube hier durch du machst
nie genau du machst den schraubendreher hier durch und die schraube klemmst du hier vorne rein
und dann kannst du quasi die schraube halten damit ohne dass du das am finger halten muss
das wenn man durch irgendwelche engen gänge durch muss ja dass das hier sind aber das
talkie brauche ich jetzt nicht oft aber die kombination hier das händel mit den einsteckern
die mag ich am liebsten
das fixet set habe ich mir auch gekauft wegen den wegen den einsätzen die leider nicht in
diesen normalen passen das fixet set habe ich mir auch gekauft weil dort dort sind halt viele
spezial einsätze drinne die man braucht beispielsweise für die steckdosen leiste die
ich letztens gekauft habe zum aufmachen die haben die haben so riesen set an so komischen
dingern die man halt normalerweise das sind die dinger die hersteller verwenden wenn sie
wollen dass man das nicht aufbekommt zum beispiel die steckdosen leiste dafür hat man den hier
gebraucht ich hatte auch letztens so eine steckdosen leiste im stream die wir versucht haben zu
flaschen dieses ding hier übrigens nicht kaufen kann man nicht flaschen weil falsche cpu drinne
und die haben diesen diesen bitt hier verwenden oder diesen auf jeden fall dreieckigen so
dreieckigen schrauben und dingen verwendet zum aufmachen also die wollten nicht dass man
das aufmachen kann ja aber dafür ist dieses fixet set ganz praktisch ich hätte ehrlich gesagt gerne
einen adapter wo ich das fixet zeug vielleicht geht hier oben was von oder so mit meinem mit
meinem normalen anderen kram verwenden kann weil dieses ding hier finde ich nicht so geil
tastatur habe ich nichts gemacht aber die bitt sind ganz praktisch das mögen zwar nicht die
allerhochwertigsten bitt sein aber man braucht ja auch nicht oft und ganz ehrlich wer hat schon
sowas daheim oder oder gut das sieht das sieht nach halbwegs normalen talks aus aber ich meine
wer hat schon sowas ich mein guckt euch das mal an welcher hersteller ist so verrückt aus
der apple ich glaube das könnten sogar die apple dinger sein die die ein kleines dreieckiges
was zum geil das machen die nur dass man es nicht aufkriegt wieso sollte man eine steckdose
flaschen das kann ich dir zeigen und zwar dass man custom firmen drauf machen kann wo man ein
menü hat dass man zum beispiel über den browser die steckdosen remote ausschalten kann und über
den browser ist das eine über die heim automatisierung die das dann entweder die
web arp oder mqtt macht ist viel besser deswegen flascht mal eine steckdose weil es mit der
standardfirmware nicht nicht geht und der zweite große vorteil ist dass diese china steckdosen
leisten eben nur mit china cloud funktionieren und nicht rein lokal das heißt entweder wenn
die also entweder hat man eh was dagegen dass man eine china cloud braucht dass man seine
steckdosen leiste schalten kann oder man möchte sicherstellen dass man seine steckdosen leiste
auch schalten kann wenn kann man das internet nicht geht
ja so sieht es aus soll wir gucken das video weiter haben wir stehen geblieben
jetzt bin ich ja mal gespannt wie sie das mit den kabeln machen ich habe ja schon welche die
ich flaschen kann ich habe ja schon welche die ich flaschen kann aber ich dachte mir halt die
die leiste die ich die leiste die ich hier gekauft habe die sieht halt exakt so aus wie die leiste
die man flaschen konnte aber da ist da ist ein mediatek cpu drinne mediatek chip den kann man
nicht flaschen man kann bloß in dem fall bei diesen steckdosen leisten nur die sachen auf
basis von esp 82 66 flaschen aber das sieht halt exakt genauso aus deswegen habe ich gedacht die
kann man flaschen kann man nicht falsche cpu aber ich habe ja noch ein paar ich habe insgesamt
drei oder vier gekauft von den die man flaschen kann wir haben ja auch im stream letztens noch
einige flaschen sehen ob es funktioniert
es gibt massig leisten zu kaufen noch die man flaschen kann
das steht drauf dass da ein mediatek drin ist ja aber das habe ich nicht gelesen
die meinen dass die meinen das wirklich ernst ok das muss fake sein das glaube
ich nicht dass sie das für jeden server machen stell euch mal vor du musst uns server einbauen
und dann machen dann patch dann dann dann krimmst du dir erstmal eigene kabel das macht keiner ok
ich sage dass ich sage ok ich sage nicht dass es keiner macht weil die machen es ja offensichtlich
ich sage das macht keiner den ich kenne und ich selbst habe es auch nicht gemacht
ich glaube das ist eher so ein halber werbefilm für den hersteller ich meine das ist ja nichts
privates das ist ja hier custodian datacenters die machen einfach indirekt damit werbung für sich
dass es halt besonders ordentlich und toll bei ihnen ist eigentlich ziemlich big brain
jetzt bin ich mal jetzt bin ich mal gespannt was die für einen für einen set verwenden ob
die so dieses klassische wir fehlen ein krimp zangen ding nehmen oder ob die die bisschen besseren
wo du wo du besser einfädeln kannst mal gucken mal gucken was sie verwenden oder aber sie zeigen
es uns gar nicht und faken das einfach mit fertigen kabel weil sie doch keinen bock drauf
haben überlegen ja genau mit wie du hast recht überlegen wir wie teuer das ist was
und techniker kostet die stunde der kabel krimpt guck mal jetzt wird sogar jetzt wird
sogar noch ab isoliert und dann mit so einem oldschool tool die machen das wirklich die
machen jetzt wirklich von handfädel action von wann ist das video 2009 ende letzten jahres das
ist neu und auch noch mit der klassischen krimp zangen da kriegst du anfälle
das ist das ist das ist pence camp das ist wirklich pence camp wenn du dir überlegst du
musst jetzt fürs komplette rack stecker drauf fuddeln orne vielleicht sind das ja ist das
ja auch azubis also ich will ihn jetzt nicht unterstellen dass es fake ist ich kann mir
durchaus vorstellen dass sie das machen aber mir wird es hardcore auf den sack gehen das zu machen
und dann erst mal schön den kabel tester dran moment die haben das reinfädeln nicht gezeigt
wo ist es wo wird reingefädelt hier wird hier moment wo ist das reinfädeln
ja und jetzt und jetzt jetzt jetzt jetzt jetzt fädel da rein man sieht es nicht
ja weil guck hier ist es schon reingefädelt also man macht das normalerweise aber man sieht
das jetzt hier nicht richtig doch jetzt eben hat man es kurz gesehen man macht das normalerweise
in so einem sehr oder sehe ich jetzt falsch normalerweise macht ne was ist das denn
normalerweise macht man dort so einen plastik ding drüber dass die gerade bleiben hat er so
was drüber nee ich glaube der macht ich glaube der macht die jolo taktik ohne plastik kann das
sein jetzt wahrscheinlich schneller ne da ist kein plastik oder leute da ist kein plastik drum
ne da schiebt es einfach so rein kann man auch machen warum nicht
und jetzt einmal drücken mit der zange
danach erst mal schön kabel testern also also normalerweise ich kenne das so dass man
im set oder so dass man dort so ein einführungs ding hat genau das was man jetzt hier nicht
sieht irgendwie nicht dabei ist okay normalerweise hat man da so ein kleines plastik ding wo man die
kabel rein steckt vorher gibt jetzt
ja ein fedel hilfe heißt das wirklich so
ja das da das da meine ich genau das da das rechts hier
es kann sein dass es da mittlerweile schon bessere varianten gibt also ich kenne das damit dass man
fädelt die kabel da rein weil ansonsten hat man das problem dass die verrutschen wenn man
sie in den stecker steckt man fädelt die kabel da rein und dann steckt man quasi die
eingefädelten kabel damit in den stecker aber gibt bestimmt verschiedene varianten
mal angenommen die bauen jetzt eine zweite netzwerkkarte in den server ein das heißt
dann wird dann jedes mal neue kabel konfektioniert oder wie da haben sie aber echt was zu tun
aber die machen es schon ordentlich muss man sagen also das ist die haben da keine
noobs am start die müssen uns mal die steckdosen zeigen dann wissen wir welches land das ist
also ist er heute deswegen haben die slot die slotplänen gefilgt da kommen
glasfaser fieberkarten also bei ihm guckt dieser dieser stöpsel quasi komplett raus und er hat
das komplett im ohr also ein bisschen druck auf den oren anscheinend steckt ja schon steckt
er fast schon halb im hirn er was ist das was ist das was ist das kenne ich nicht
ach das ist kabel sortieren das ist kabel eine bündelungshilfe was es nicht alles gibt
aha ok aber eines gutes ist sie machen klettverschlüsse drum ich finde klettverschlüsse
auch viel angenehmer als kabelbinder weil kabelbinder muss man immer wieder aufschneiden
wieder neu machen und ordentlich ist das noch kann man nichts sagen haben die da irgendwie
ein spezielles system was blau ist und was rote kabel gibt also ordentlich sieht das
aus bin mal gespannt wie es zum schluss ausschaut machen sie es auch noch richtig ordentlich
am rack fest guckt euch das mal an hier
weißt du noch 2006 als halb europa für paar stunden ohne strom war also ich glaube mich
hat es nicht betroffen weil dann wüsste ich das vielleicht habe ich aber einfach auf
dem klo gesessen in der zwischenzeit habe nichts mitgekriegt wobei 2006 kann nicht sein
2006 hatte ich ja noch nicht den den high end klo ne ne ne da nicht ne kann ich mich
nicht mehr dran erinnern ich kann mich noch dran erinnern wo irgendeine router konfig
in tschechien oder so eine falsche falsche router konfig in tschechien irgendwie das halbe
internet alarm gelegt hat weil das weil das falsche usbf oder bgp netze propagiert hat
das ist auch so in dem dreh gewesen die die die mein die mein das ernst die meint
das ok dann hast du da hast du echt was zu tun wenn du die kabel wirklich exakt zum
server konfig sind das sieht cool aus am ende aber das ist echt aufwendig doch die haben
die kabel angeblich gelabelt haben sie zumindest erzählt
das sieht richtig gut ordentlich aus das kann man nicht schlecht ich meine das sieht wirklich
gut aus also das wirklich gut gemacht
aber es hat aufwendig erst fack ne oh es klopft an der tür wartet war von ks
ist auch wieder da
100 prozent wirft der kunde die reste sofort weg ich weiß gar nicht ob die der kunde jemals
zu gesicht bekommt ich hätte eher gedacht das ist bei denen im data center die hosten
dort für irgendjemand was vielleicht können vielleicht können die techniker vielleicht
können die techniker das kupfer im kabel zu geld machen wachs hast du eine freundin
das weihnachtsgrill ja das wusste es muss jetzt natürlich mal wieder irgendjemand ansprechen
ja ist klar ich habe schon wieder verdrängt aber der chat der merkt sich sowas so gucken
wir als nächstes gucken wir überhaupt was als nächstes ich glaube ich esse was jetzt
ich glaube ich esse jetzt was chat wobei ich gucke mir noch kurz an wie man den
amazon firestick die blutet wobei schauen ob sie gucken ob es aber sinnvoll ist wie heißt
dieser kabelball oder das habe ich vergessen wie das heißt das haben die im stream gesagt
ich habe sowas selbst noch nie verwendet okay das video ist langweilig liegt das ist
raus gibt es ein tool mit welchem man seinen ping zu einem gaming server live sehen kann
ja mit ping also du musst halt nur die ip rauskriegen die die fahre wurde dich hinkonekt
ist wenn das ganz genau wissen willst wahrscheinlich könntest du einen wire shark anmachen und
die verbindung mitschneiden von deiner gaming session und dann gucken aber ansonsten fällt
mir da und das aber muss antworten genau das ist übrigens auch die sache ist muss ich
jetzt noch mal muss ich jetzt noch mal kurz loswerden weiß gar nicht das sehe ich nämlich
so oft falsch das muss ich euch jetzt mal kurz zeigen dass es gibt ja so es gibt ja
total viele videos auf youtube überall die erzählen so nach dem motto hier so fix die
eure connection und sowas so und eine sache die da immer gezeigt wird die aber totaler
blödsinn ist ist dass die trace root machen oder trace trace rt unter unter windows kommt
aufs gleiche raus und dann daran sagen oh ihr habt packet loss das ist totaler totaler
schwachsinn ich zeige euch das jetzt mal das ist der da cringe sich bei mir nehme ich immer
alles wenn ich das sehe also trace root machen die diesen oh habe ich gar nicht installiert
moment ich muss erst mal trace root installieren
so wir machen jetzt mal trace root sagt mir mal irgendwas was brauche bettel.net so und
jetzt fällt euch schon was auf das an manchen stellen was nicht so ganz antwortet und wenn
gar nichts mehr antworten hört ihr irgendwann noch auf ich glaube noch 30 hops oder so
so und hier zum beispiel hier hier antwortet fast nicht so und die sache ist jetzt die es
gibt es gibt so so tutorial videos so nach dem motto so fix die eure connection und die
sagen denn ja macht man einen trace root irgendwo hin und dann sind da solche hops dazwischen
dann sagen die oh packet loss oh packet loss ist aber schwachsinn stimmt überhaupt nicht
hat mit packet loss überhaupt nichts zu tun das einzige was es an dieser stelle sagt ist
dass dieser eine router auf der strecke nicht auf ICMP antwortet das ist alles das ist das
ist alles das sagt nichts zu packet loss aus oder nichts zur verbindung nichts es sagt
es sagt im endeffekt nichts aus gar nichts weil wie so wie so ein trace root funktioniert
ich versuche das mal relativ kurz kurz zu erklären also jedes paket hat eine lebenszeit
dran stehen weil warum macht man das chat big brain an die die fachinformatiker oder
sowas gelernt haben warum steht an einem paket in der time to live oder lebenszeit ran oder
wie viele sachen über wie viele router das ganze weitergeleitet werden kann warum gibt
so was überhaupt muss jetzt muss der chat auch mal was machen oder chat hat nicht aufgepasst
damit nicht unendlich zirkulieren können korrekt ja also chat der chat hat recht chat
kennt sich natürlich aus das ist damit die sachen nicht unendlich lange im kreis rum
geroutet werden ja ich weiß es gibt es gibt mehrere trace root varianten aber die standard
trace root variante ist die man schickt ein paket und setzt das auf time to live erstmal
auf eins so und was ein router macht wenn er so ein paket kriegt ist er nimmt das paket
an will das weiterleiten aber während er das weiterleitet macht er zählt er das eins
runter so dass quasi am letzten router das paket verworfen wird und deswegen schickt
man erstmal ein paket los mit time to live eins das bedeutet der router der das zuerst
bekommt verwirft das paket und schickt eine fehlermeldung zurück so dann schickt man
das nächste paket mit time to live zwei dann schickt der nächste router eine fehlermeldung
zurück und so weiter und so fort so das einzige was das hier bedeutet ist dass dieser router
keine fehlermeldung zurückschickt wenn er das paket verwirft das ist alles das hat mit
packet loss nichts zu tun das verwirft das paket weil die time to live abgelaufen ist
allerdings steht in eurem gaming paket nicht time to live drei sondern was anderes das
ist totaler schwachsinn so und das hier heißt im endeffekt auch nur dass die anderen hops
nicht antworten fertig das ist das ist alles also diese ganzen videos die es dazu gibt
so nach dem auto packet loss auf stufe auf hopp drei ist kompletter schwachsinn hopp
drei ist in dem fall auch der eingang bei unity media du schickst deine pakete mit time
to live 69 excellent so muss was machen oder mit 420 oder wobei warte mal ist das höchste
nicht 255 was ist max time to live was ist maximal time to live 255 ok also gut da bleibt
ja bloß 69 was man rein machen kann 420 geht ja nicht aber 420 wäre auch eher die mlg
paketlänge wenn schon 22 das geht auch aber 42 ist old school 42 ist die boomer die jugend
von heute schreibt 69 rein was sonst glaubst du bei dhl gibt es paketlost und wie es das
gibt hatte ich selbst schon öfters so jetzt haben wir noch was gelernt chat und jetzt
kann ich essen gehen aber nehme ich hier wieder aus kennst du schon den google tv stick ne
aber ich bin mit meinem schild tv so glücklich dass ich mir nichts neues hole ist bei dir
scrolling in der vm auch laggy ich habe manchmal das gefühl dass ein paar scroll kommandos
verloren gehen ja so ich geh jetzt was essen leute wir sehen uns gucken ob der friseur
online ist dann host dich stehen wenn der friseur nicht online ist dann host dich kein der frasier
ist an leute huge der frasier himself spielt ja ja ja ja ja ja ja ja ja ja ja ja ja ja
warum vor allem kein hyper wie weil das vor allem eine workstation ist und desktop virtualisierung
besser geht so da ist er der frasier der wird jetzt gehostet oder geradet wieder
ja irgendwie geweep käme seine name startensa
Na gut
Machen wir geradeaus
Also noch ein...
So wir raiden den Frisör, machts gut
Bis zum nächsten Strief, See you!